Moin Leute, heute Nacht, ne, musste ich mega Monka essen, aber richtig, ich hab gedacht, was ist denn da los, ähm, jetzt kurz die Musik leiser machen, oder irgendwas anderes anmachen, gleich deutlich, deutlich entspannter, wie gesagt, heute Nacht muss ich mega, mega Monka essen, und zwar, ich hab ja gestern erzählt, ich hab immer nachts ein bisschen Livestream auf dem Handy laufen, irgendwann kackt es auch mal ab, und ich hab die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund heute Nacht,
ähm, also, was heißt die ganze Zeit, also, ich war so, so halb, so leicht wach, also, leicht am Schlafen, sagen wir mal so, und ich hab im Hintergrund, hab ich gehört, dass es irgendwie macht so,
und ich dachte, das ist irgendwas aus dem Livestream, ja, weil ich hab ja immer, ich hab ja immer ein bisschen Livestream laufen im Hintergrund, wenn ich am Pennen bin auf dem Handy,
so, und, äh, irgendwann bin ich dann aufgewacht, hab mir gedacht, was ist das für ein komisches Geräusch, das wiederholt sich,
und, äh,
dann hab ich festgestellt, der Livestream ist aus, Handy war aus,
das heißt, irgendwo aus meinem Zimmer kamen Geräusche, also, irgendwo aus meinem Schlafzimmer kamen Geräusche, die ich noch nie vorher gehört hab, und ich absolut nicht zuordnen konnte,
ich hab an jedem Handy gelauscht, ihr kennt das vielleicht, manchmal liegst du dann im Bett, und denkst dir, okay, wo kommt das her, links, rechts, eher von links,
na, okay, hab ich am ersten Smartphone Ohr dran gehalten, von da kam's nicht,
zweien Smartphone das Ohr dran gehalten, kam's auch nicht,
an Tablet, als Tablet das Ohr,
an Tablet das Ohr dran gehalten, da kam's auch nicht her,
aber ich, wie hab ich gedacht,
okay, was ist das, ist das irgendein Viech in der Klimaanlage, oder was ist das,
was ist, nee, es war auch nicht die Katz,
also, das, das, äh, hört sich anders an,
außerdem, außerdem rührt die sich dann, wenn sie sieht, dass ich, äh, mich bewege, so,
aber zumindest, ich hab gesagt, keine Ahnung, wo kommt das her,
da, da hab ich mich ins Bett gesetzt, also, noch Licht aus, alles, ja,
äh, hab ich mich ins Bett gesetzt, hab so Kopf gedreht, so von links, von rechts, von, ich konnte es nicht genau an,
es war auch unterschiedlich laut, nicht immer, immer,
immer, immer, äh, gleich laut, nicht immer,
hat sich nicht gleich angehört, aber so ganz komisch,
ich hab erst gedacht, okay,
ich hab irgendein Viech in der Klimaanlage,
irgendwas, was in die Klimaanlage reingekommen ist,
von außen, irgendwie, wie auch immer,
und da jetzt drinnen rum,
abkratzen ist, oder so,
keine Ahnung, oder aber,
und das ist ja, äh, wo ich ein bisschen,
äh, warte mal, hab ich,
noch ein,
MonkaGiga-Emote, oder so,
nee, keine Ahnung, wo ich ja eher so ein bisschen
mehr Bedenken hab, ist,
dass ich irgendwelche,
fetten Viecher bei mir im Zimmer hab,
so, sei es jetzt irgendwelche,
zwei Meter großen Spinnen, oder so,
die komische Geräusche nachts machen.
Habt ihr schon mal eine Spinne
laufen hören?
Ey, es ist voll erbarlich, ja,
wir hatten mal so ein riesen Viech im Bad,
in der alten Wohnung, ja, zumindest,
ähm, also, so, so, so Dinger will ich nicht,
ich hab, ich, das muss nicht sein,
da hab ich dann ein bisschen Panik davor gehabt,
Alter, was ist das?
So, zumindest, lange, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich mach's Licht an,
und guck mal ein bisschen rum,
wisst ihr was, es war im Endeffekt,
es war die Flasche mit Sprudelwasser,
die nicht richtig zu war,
aber, es hat sich, es hat sich ganz merkwürdig,
ihr, ihr kennt das Geräusch, was, was Sprudelwasser
macht, wenn der, wenn, wenn der Deckel
nicht richtig zu ist, ne, das macht, das macht halt so,
so vor sich hin, und dann immer mit Pause,
und, ey, ich hab da, ey, ich, das, das Geräusch,
das hab ich noch nie wirklich so wahrgenommen vorher,
ich hab übelst Panik gekriegt, ne,
ich hab gesagt, ey, was ist denn jetzt hier,
und da hab ich gesagt, oh, ja, das ist die Sprudelwasser,
oder die Sprudelflasche, äh, Wassersprudel,
äh, die Sprudelwasserflasche,
schweres Wort, Alter,
ja,
da hab ich richtig gemonka esst,
heute Nacht,
danach hab ich ja innerlich ein bisschen keck weht,
als ich gesehen hab,
dass es die, äh,
Sprudelflasche ist,
ja,
die Sodastreamflasche,
ja, genau, so eine haben wir auch,
das Ding ist übrigens richtig,
damals hieß es noch Sodaclub,
mittlerweile heißt es Sodastream,
aber so ein Teil hab ich schon seit
20 Jahren oder so,
äh, ewig,
also ich, ich trag schon lange keine Kisten mit Wasser mehr hoch,
weil ich Plastikflaschen hab,
das ist richtig nice,
das Einzige, was man manchmal holen muss,
ist so eine, so eine Pressluftsprudel,
was auch immer das ist, Flasche, ne,
aber es ist richtig nice,
äh,
äh, Maddox sagt, ihr müsst mal eine 5cm Spinne,
und, unter die Tastatur gelaufen,
ich hab's nur aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen,
alter MonkaS,
ähm, das Schlimme ist,
ja, also, es gibt, es gibt zwei Sachen,
und das sind eigentlich auch so die einzigen Sachen,
wo ich echt Schiss vor hab,
also du kannst mich weder mit Schlangen,
noch mit Mäusen, noch mit irgendwas anderes schocken,
ja, auch, auch mit eklichem Krams,
ja,
sei es irgendwie hingekotzt, hingeschissen,
was auch immer, juckt mich alles nicht,
ist mir alles egal,
es gibt zwei Sachen, aber zwei komplett,
unterschiedliche Paar Sachen, vor denen ich Schiss hab,
das erste ist,
tiefes Wasser,
frag mich nicht warum, keine Ahnung,
aber ich glaub, das haben viele,
aber lustigerweise, nur wenn ich schwimme,
wenn ich tauche, ist okay,
ist merkwürdig,
also wenn ich, wenn ich schwimme,
sei es in irgendeinem See, oder so,
äh, schwimme,
wenn ich nicht genau weiß, wie tief es drunter ist,
geht schon teilweise im, im, ähm,
im Sprungbecken,
vom Schwimmbad los, wenn ich weiß, ah, es ist 3,50m oder so tief,
ähm,
dann, und vor allem, wenn du dann oben drauf stehst,
dann ist es dann nochmal,
äh, drei, ist es dann nochmal so hoch von oben,
wenn du guckst, ja,
da hab ich, da hab ich übel Schiss vor,
wobei, lustigerweise, wenn ich dann reingehe,
also, wenn ich,
manchmal, es gibt ja, es gibt ja,
so, so Sprungbecken mit 10-Meter-Bretter,
ist es dann auch 3,50m irgendwie tief,
dass halt die Leute nicht aufklatschen,
und, ähm,
wenn ich dann einfach so ins Wasser gehe,
und da runtertauche, überhaupt kein Problem,
juckt mich nicht, finde ich sogar interessant,
gerade, gerade im Dings, äh,
wie heißt das Schwimmbad in Frankfurt,
ob es das überhaupt noch gibt,
war das Taunus, Taunus-Therme,
Taunus-Therme,
ne, äh,
Moment, wie heißt das,
ah, das mach ich nicht,
wie heißt dann das, eine Schwimmbad
in Frankfurt mit,
mit der großen, großen Rutsche,
da gibt's doch, war das nicht die Taunus-Therme,
äh,
Rebstockbad, meine ich, genau,
Rebstockbad in Frankfurt,
nein, ich,
ich bin nicht so profimäßig wie der Krieger,
ähm, zumindest das Schwimmbad,
da bin ich früher übelst gern hin mit meinem Vater gegangen,
weil die haben, so, äh,
so eine Wellen, Wellenstelz,
also da hinten ist so ein Ding, was Wellen macht,
da kannst du dich dann
da rumwellen lassen, so,
ähm, zumindest die haben
ein Becken, wo man reinsprungt,
ein Brett, die haben, ich weiß nicht, ob es davon Bilder,
gibt. Genau.
So. Das ist das
Becken. Das geht bis zu 10 Meter.
Geht bis zu 10 Meter oder 7 Meter.
Doch, ich glaube 10 Meter. Zumindest geht es
relativ hoch hier zum Unterspringen.
Und hier unten haben die
ein Fenster drin.
Kennst du Wellenbad in China?
Ja, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Wo die Leute auf einen Haufen von der Welle
geschmissen werden.
Hier unten, also da hatte ich übel Schiss
reinzugehen in das Wasser,
weil es so tief ist. Also das hat
Runterspringen 10 Meter hat mich auch nicht geschockt.
Ey, ich hatte damals sogar den
goldenen Dings-Freischwimmer
oder wie das Ding hieß. Ja, diese Abzeichen,
die man immer so an die Badehose gepappt
hat und es richtig geil vorkam.
Ja, und zumindest
hier unten haben die ein Fenster
drin in diesem Sprungbecken.
Und
da bin ich
dann immer runtergetaucht und hab durchgeguckt.
Irgendwann hab ich festgestellt, hinter diesem Fenster
ist halt irgend so ein Maintenance-Ding.
So ein Maintenance-
Tunnel, wo manchmal Leute
durchlaufen.
Da bin ich dann irgendwie gefühlt
den halben Tag da runtergetaucht, nur um den Leuten
zu winken, wenn da mal einer durch den Tunnel geläuft.
Kommst du aus
Frankfurt? Ja.
Ja, also das Rebstockbad, da bin ich früher echt
gerne hingegangen. Also das ist super Bad.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt in
Frankfurt, ob das überhaupt noch offen ist.
Keine Ahnung, ob es das noch gibt.
Keine Ahnung mehr. Anscheinend doch, doch gibt es noch.
Aber das ist auch für Familien
ein super Ausflug. Du hast hier einmal
was recht seichtes.
Du hast dieses Wellenmaschinen-Ding.
Du hast Sprungbretter. Du kannst ins
Freie raus und
du hast eine richtig geile Rutsche.
Die geht irgendwie, frag mich nicht,
300 Meter oder so. Die geht von
hier oben hier rein, raus ins Freie
und runter. Also die
Rutsche ist echt nice.
Guck mal hier, die Rutsche ist echt nice.
Also da geht
einiges mit der Rutsche.
Die haben das
mittlerweile zugemacht.
Also früher war in den Kurven
auf jeden Fall noch oben offen.
Früher war in den Kurven
oder außen definitiv noch oben offen.
Wahrscheinlich wurden die Leute
getriggert,
weil
sie sonst aus dem Dach fallen
könnten. Okay, Rebstock, Bad, Frankfurt, ja, das
gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Übrigens,
das sind die Noobs, die
also rutschen,
rutschen auf dem Rücken und rutschen auf dem Bobbes
ist low skill.
Ja, wäre richtig,
schnell, wer richtig schnell
Wasserrutschen rutschen will,
der nimmt Anlauf und springt rein
und rutscht auf den Knien runter.
Das ist jetzt kein Ritz, das geht übelst ab.
Das flutscht richtig.
So richtig mit
Anlauf, es ist,
ich kenne das Hauptstel aus irgendwelchen FIFA
Games,
wo die dann Fußballjubel
machen, so rennen und springen und so
auf den Knien über den Rasen rutschen.
So musst du in die Rutsche
springen, dann geht es richtig ab.
Okay, nackter
Ball,
Bobbes geht auch. Allerdings nackter Bobbes im öffentlichen
Schwimmbad ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Wie groß soll die Rutsche sein?
Wieso? Kein Problem.
Also ich rede jetzt ja auch nicht davon, dass
der ausgewachsene Zwei-Meter-Mann reingeht.
So ein Kinderhaushalt.
Ich bin da immer voll reingesprungen, auf die
Knie runtergerutscht. Das geht übelst ab.
Dann habe ich unten kein Knie mehr.
Quatsch, überhaupt kein Problem.
Das rutscht ja, das ist ja eine Rutsche.
So, also gucken wir uns mal an.
Die war auch blau früher.
Die war doch, die war doch nicht aus Metall.
Die war doch ziemlich sicher.
War die blau und aus Plastik früher?
Äh, Emotes.
Bald.
Ja, da bist du schon eine Weile unterwegs hier, ne?
Also die Rutsche geht,
die Rutsche geht wirklich schon, die geht eine ganze Weile.
Äh, Moment, Hyper S.
Und der ist auch recht schnell unterwegs.
Doch, früher war das definitiv offen.
Früher war es in den Kurven offen oben,
die Rutsche. Und es war nur an den Kurven
an der Seite so ein bisschen was, dass die Leute
nicht rausgefallen sind. Wahrscheinlich hatten die Leute
Panik, dass sie rausfallen aus der Rutsche.
Aber heute haben sie ja alle, hatte jeder, jeder, jeder
vor jedem alles irgendwie Panik.
Geht sogar so weit.
Gibt's da noch was von früher?
Hebstock, Bart, Rutsche.
Gibt's da noch von früher Aufnahmen?
Weil so sah es definitiv
nicht aus früher.
In der Rutsche geht...
Woah! MonkaS, Alter.
Was geht mit denen ab?
Die war, früher war die blau und teilweise
offen.
Deswegen sag ich, man muss auf die Knien runterrutschen.
Dann geht's ab. Ne, gibt's anscheinend
keine, keine Bilder mehr. Aber da bin ich früher
extrem gerne hin.
Moin!
Chronix, der Knärbe ist auch am Start.
JZ, der
Knallbusch. Das sind ja richtig viele
Leute schon da hier.
Ja, zumindest
eine extrem leise
Geschichte. Ja, und das
hat mich heute Nacht halt geschockt.
Weiß jetzt auch. Wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich auf diese
komische... Ach ja, äh,
genau. Und hier noch was, noch was,
noch was zum Thema, zum Thema Rutsche.
Weil ich ja gesagt hab, früher
...
Früher war das hier nicht überdacht
außen und auch nur an den, nur in den
Kurven, im Deckel drüber. Ich hab da
das Gefühl, dass die mittlerweile Schiss haben, dass die Leute rausfallen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, woran's liegt,
ob das aus irgendwelchen Haftungsgründen ist
oder sonst wo, dass ganz viele
Sachen, die früher
ähm, also
dass viele Sachen früher anders gebaut haben. Zum Beispiel
war es so, ich bin letztens wieder
mal an der Schule vorbeigelaufen, wo ich
ähm, wo ich halt in die
Schule gegangen bin. Also in beiden.
Vorbeigelaufen. Sogar die
Grundschule war abgesperrt. Früher
war die Grundschule immer komplett auf, weil da ist so
ein Übungsplatz gewesen, wo man
äh, Fahrradfahren und äh,
mit, mit Verkehrsschildern
üben konnte auf dem Schulgelände.
Alles, alles abgeschlossen und sogar
extra Schild dran, dass du nicht betreten darfst.
Und die andere Schule, wo ich danach hingegangen bin,
konntest du früher auch ohne Probleme
von vorne nach hinten durchlaufen.
Ähm, hast du halt
in der Regel nur gemacht, wenn halt keine Pause
war, weil sonst ein bisschen merkwürdig ist,
wenn du einfach nicht in die Schule gehst und da random drüberläufst.
Aber das war komplett offen.
Heute komplett eingezäunt.
Komplett Zaun drum. Vor was haben
die eigentlich Schiss?
Vor was haben
die da Schiss? Dass die Leute äh,
zu dumm sind und, und sich verlaufen
auf dem Hof, wenn da kein Zaun drum rum ist
oder, oder wie? Ich glaub ja
eher, dass das da dran liegt,
dass ähm,
mittlerweile die Leute durch jeden Scheiß triggert
sind, so nach dem Motto, oh nein, da könnte ja was
passieren, wenn da kein Zaun drum rum ist.
Was soll da passieren?
Ich frag mich eh,
ich frag mich eh, wie das funktioniert hat. Man muss sich
mal vorstellen, als ich in die
Schule gegangen bin, sind die meisten
Leute entweder,
es gab drei, drei Sachen. Es gab die,
die mit dem Bus gekommen sind, die sind aber ein bisschen weiter weg,
welche, die mit dem Fahrrad gefahren sind,
und ähm,
die, die gelaufen sind. So, ich
hab so ein Zwischending zwischen Fahrradfahren und Laufen
gemacht. Für Bus war ich, war ich
zu nah dran. So,
und, mittlerweile
ist es so, ich bin ja, wie gesagt, ich bin ja letztens
an der Schule vorbeigelaufen,
die haben
gegenüber und rechts
quasi Parkplätze
und hinten, noch ein, zwei dahinten
noch mal eine riesen Abhol-Entladezone,
wo ich mir denke, okay,
anscheinend
holen heute 90% der Eltern
Kinder in die Schule
ab und bringen sie wieder. Wie geht das überhaupt,
wenn man arbeiten geht?
Es hätte mich früher überhaupt, ja doch, mein Opa hätte
mich früher abholen können, vielleicht.
Aber ist,
ist das so, ist das
so schlimm, die Welt heutzutage,
dass man, äh,
seinen Kindern nicht mehr
zutrauen kann,
eine Viertelstunde von der Schule
heimzulaufen und zurück?
Ich mein, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre jetzt
die Welt wahnsinnig
gefährlicher geworden, als
vor 20 Jahren.
Ach, ich weiß auch nicht. Merkwürdig.
Vielleicht,
es sind vielleicht einfach andere Zeit, ja.
Gut, heute hast du
ne Leute mit der Axt in der, in der, in der,
im, im, im RB,
der mit der, der mit der Axt
auf die Leute zurennt, ja. Das hast du
vielleicht, früher war das nicht so präsent,
dass sowas passiert ist.
Ist bestimmt auch passiert, aber man hat
nicht so oft und nicht so, nicht so groß.
Ähm,
aber,
also ich glaube nicht, dass es so großartig,
großartig gefährlicher ist, heute, eine Viertelstunde
von der Schule heimzulaufen, als vor 20 Jahren.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Also, merkwürdig.
Und irgendwie sind die Leute bei, bei vielem
heute direkt getriggert, dass das ultra gefährlich
ist und dir bei allem irgendwas passieren kann.
Ich frag mich, ich frag mich ganz ernst, es war ja,
das war ja bei mir schon so, dass
bei uns, wir waren ja schon relativ behütet,
muss man sagen, ja, also, bei uns haben ja auch immer
die Leute aufgepasst, sei es,
sei es die Eltern, sei es Opa, Oma, sonst wie,
dass, dass alles in Ordnung gewesen ist. Ich frag
mich ganz ernsthaft, wie hat
das die Generation von,
von Opa
und Oma überhaupt, jetzt mal den zweiten Weltkrieg
außen vor, ja, wenn die
ein bisschen später, wie haben die das überlebt,
alle? Da war
ja nix. Ist ja,
da gab's dann teilweise
Familien mit sechs Kindern
und die mussten sich die ganze Zeit irgendwie mit sich
selbst beschäftigen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das überlebt haben,
ja.
Wie soll das überhaupt gehen?
Ohne,
ohne Internet. Die mussten rausgehen.
Kann man sich das vorstellen? Ich kann mir das
auch nicht mal vorstellen. Die mussten rausgehen
und da irgendwas machen.
Ins Freie.
Das ist ja, es ist ja echt Massive Pains Champ.
An die Sonne und sowas, ne.
Also mal im Ernst.
Wer will denn, wer will denn sowas?
Ohne Internet und alles, ja.
Mit Freunden auf dem
Spielplatz.
Ja, sowas, sowas kommt ja heute nicht mehr vor.
Heute ist eher mit Freunden Fortnite angesagt.
Und damals, ne,
damals waren wir noch die, die,
die, so
die Außenseiter des Youtube-Channels.
Wie soll man das nennen? Ja doch, damals waren wir noch
eher die Außenseiter, weil man sich hingesetzt hat
mit fünf Leuten und
CS gespielt hat, anstatt
irgendwelche coolen
Aktionen zu machen, ja.
Naja.
Was ist denn das? Aufklärungsvideo, Netzwerk,
Kabel und Stecker.
Das ist bestimmt mega langweilig, oder?
Leute,
Fortnite-Tänze tanzen.
Ich hab das ja nicht für möglich gehalten, dass die Leute wirklich so
degeneriert im Kopf sind, was Fortnite-Tänze
angeht. Aber nachdem ich vor nem
Jahr oder so, mal am Südbahnhof
keine Ahnung, ne Gruppe,
was waren das, 10-Jähriger oder so, gesehen hab,
die vor die S-Bahn oder vor den
Bus, ne, vor die, vor die, vor die,
vor die Straßenbahn, schwachsinn, was?
Vor die Straßenbahn gehüpft sind.
Die Straßenbahn hält am Südbahnhof.
Und da sind die vor die Straßenbahn
gehüpft und haben den Loser-Dance gemacht.
Auf der, auf der Gleise.
Und
ich, ich dachte ja wirklich, die Leute sind
nicht so degeneriert.
Aber,
doch.
Sind sie.
Ein, OneHead,
da ist, da ist hier,
da ist Dreikopf nicht mehr
genug. Das muss doch eins,
da geht noch eins tiefer. Direkt
umgefahren, ne, natürlich passen die auf.
Okay, was erklärt er uns?
Netzwerkkabel?
Direkt da drunter befindet sich der
Okay, ne, das Video ist langweilig.
Oh, ne. Das ist Theorie-Crafting
elf Minuten. Ne, ne, ne, das gucken wir uns
nicht an. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Also,
Police Car, or just Kokona
Things.
Da steht einfach, was ist denn,
M16 oder so, oder M4? Da hängt
einfach mal ein, das ist, das ist halt, hell,
hell yeah, brother!
Moment,
aber, also, das
ausrangierte Polizeifahrzeug,
was er da hat,
das wurde nicht mit Waffe geliefert, oder?
Also, die Waffe hat er schon
selbst reingemacht. Ich meine, ich trau den,
alles zu, sowohl den,
als auch den, trau ich alles zu
in der Richtung, ja. Wobei, den,
den, den eher, den eher.
Also, den würde ich, also den Amis würde ich
ohne Probleme zutrauen, dass,
ähm, sie ein Polizeiauto
ausmustern, inklusive
M4. Das würde mich nicht wundern.
Moment, Moment,
es gibt kein Kokona-Emote mehr?
Warum, warum
geht das Kokona-Emote im Chat bei mir nicht?
Haben die Kokona entfernt?
Echt? Bei mir geht Kokona
nicht? Hat sich vielleicht
mein FFZ irgendwie verabschiedet?
Ja, mein FFZ hat sich
verabschiedet.
Moment, ich muss mal meinen Chat reloaden, ich glaub,
das schwackt rum. Moment.
Kokona?
Ah, jetzt funktioniert
es wieder. Ok.
Das sieht das Ganze auch nicht aus, ne?
Daniel, Dankeschön.
Excellent. Monarch S.
What?
Moment.
Einfach wackeln mit dem Schlüssel?
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Das ging aber
schnell.
Das ging aber schnell.
Na gut, du, wenn, wenn du da Leute
erschießen musst, dann muss das zackig gehen.
Lockt.
Unlockt.
Ok. Excellent.
Excellent Schloss.
Made in the USA.
Unlockt.
Lockt.
Folks, I get really frustrated
when I see products like this.
They're expensive locks with a deadly
serious purpose. It's simply
inexcusable, in my opinion, that they can
be defeated in a few moments with a
zero-skill attack.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
If you do have any questions or comments
about this, please put them below.
If you like this video and would like to see
more like it, please subscribe.
And as always, have a nice day.
Thank you.
Wahrscheinlich im Kofferraum, ne?
Ansonsten ist ja ein bisschen wenig Platz.
Oder an den Türen oder so.
Ich trau denen alles zu, keine Ahnung.
Aber heftig. So, was haben wir sonst noch zu tun?
Essentials to you will need electronic projects.
Future of Diablo.
How safe is the so-
What?
Ich hoffe, das Video ist nicht blutig.
Gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
Bisschen leise, hä?
Table saw causes the most accidents
of any tool in the garage
or the shop.
Ganz einfach, muss man einfach aufpassen.
You know, I have a saw stop,
so this isn't something I worry about
as much anymore, but I've always
wanted to know, how safe is
a saw stop.
Was ist überhaupt ein saw stop?
Also, ich kann mir anhand des Namens ja was
zusammenreimen. Es ist was, was
die Säge stoppt.
Auf die Idee sind wir wahrscheinlich alle schon gekommen.
Aber, was
es genau ist, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Der erkennt den Finger
und stoppt die Säge.
Wie soll das denn den Finger erkennen?
Ja, vor allem, okay, wie man den Finger
erkennt, das könnte ich mir noch vorstellen,
dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert, aber
wie will man das schnell stoppen?
Ich mein, das Ding
ist, guck mal, so ein
Sägeplatt,
keine Ahnung, mit was ich das drehe,
10.000 Umdrehungen die Minute,
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Das müsstest du ja dann quasi
so extrem schnell stoppen,
dass wahrscheinlich
das Sägeplatt zerbricht oder so.
So.
Excellent.
Das hat eine serielle Schnittstelle,
sehe ich das richtig?
Hat einen Comport dran.
2020,
excellent.
Also, wenn schon,
will ich einen Source-Dot mit USB haben.
Und HDMI.
4K.
So let's talk about the test.
So, we did the test
on my 5-horsepower ICS
SawStop, which is an industrial cabinet saw.
I used to have the PCS in some of my older videos,
that's the professional cabinet saw,
but recently we upgraded and we got the
over-arm dust collection, which
is awesome by the way. You should check out that
compilation video I posted last Sunday
of all our slow-motion.
Der will nicht seine Sägespäne in der Werkstatt rumfliegen haben,
das kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
It's got some cool dust collection shots,
regular dust collection shoots.
We used Nathan Ballpark Franks,
they were about the size of my thumb,
that's why I used them, about one inch in diameter.
We did six regular activations with a 10.
Ey, wenn er echt Vertrauen in den SawStop hätte,
würde er es mit seinem Finger machen.
And three DatoStack activations
with an 8-inch blade.
The 5-horsepower ICS is the second most
powerful saw that SawStop has,
so you could know that,
if you have a PCS or a lower model saw,
that they have the same exact tech
and break cartridges in them,
the tests would perform even better
on your machine.
Their top-of-the-line one, I think,
is 7-horsepower, but basically
this is the biggest and baddest
half-Sands-on-Saw,
and you know...
It's going to do some damage
to these break cartridges.
Alright, let's talk about what happens
when you cause an activation.
We're going to show you regular speed first,
followed by the high-speed slow-motion footage,
and then I'm going to walk you through
what happens when you cause an activation.
Go, go!
Oh, das ist ne...
Ist das ne Wurst?
Boah, ey, das geht ja mega schnell!
Vor allem, das Ding ist richtig clever,
dass, ähm...
das stoppt,
so wie es sich anhört,
und geht gleichzeitig runter.
Das ist eigentlich, äh...
Also, weißt du,
das ist eigentlich schon eher so hier.
Am mindestens so.
Das ist ein Salami.
Guck mal hier!
The fuck! Guck mal wie sch...
Alter, ey, das geht richtig gut!
Guck mal hier!
Okay, hier hat's ein bisschen reingekratzt.
Ich mein, das ist jetzt nicht so das
Problem am Finger, das blutet ein bisschen,
aber okay. Funktioniert das ungefähr
wie ein F.I. im Haus? Nee, bestimmt nicht.
Das muss ja
irgendwie blocken. Alter!
Guck mal, habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell das stoppt?
Guck mal hier!
Zack!
Das sind ja Millisekunden, ey!
Und es ist
direkt weg!
Krass, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das so schnell geht.
Von der Erkennung am Finger dran.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Hoffentlich erklärt das uns.
Ist ja nice.
Ah!
Ah, okay.
Die, die, die...
Also sprich, die leiten irgendwie
3 Volt Spannung durch das Sägeblatt
und wenn das irgendwie abfällt,
weil du mit dem Finger dran kommst,
löst instant die Bremse aus.
Und die Bremse ist auch keine
Bremse im eigentlichen Sinn,
sondern es ist einfach ein Stück Metall,
was direkt blockiert.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich das Sägeblatt danach
auch im Arsch.
Guck mal hier, was da für Zeug rumfliegt,
wenn das rein basht.
Guck mal hier!
Bam!
Das Sägeblatt ist voll im Arsch wahrscheinlich
danach. Aber das, ich mein,
ganz ehrlich, besser
der Finger noch dran, als das
Sägeblatt im... also nee.
Besser Sägeblatt im Arsch und Finger noch dran,
aber Finger ab und Sägeblatt gut.
Ja, guck mal hier, das ist auf jeden Fall
RIP danach.
Guck mal, wie das...
Seht ihr, wie sich das Sägeblatt zerlegt?
Also das Sägeblatt zerlegt
sich halb und zerlegt dabei noch
die Bremse halb. Guck mal.
Und...
Und so
dein Blatt, welches
eine Standard-Kurve-Blatt ist, wiegt etwa 2
Pound, stoppt bei etwa 1.000
Gs von Kraft. Nun, um das zu vergleichen,
das wäre wie ein Fliegerpilot
in eine Konkretwalle
bei 1.000 Meilen pro Stunde. Wir haben
nicht wirklich einen Bezug, um es zu vergleichen,
zu etwas, was wir erleben können. Aber du kannst
hier von unseren fünf Hotdogs sehen, hier sind
ein paar Schotten von ihnen. Es stoppt so schnell,
dass es nicht mal einen Hotdog zerlässt.
Wenn das du wärst, würde ich das nicht mal ausdrucken.
Und ich habe mich persönlich schon
von meinem Saustop ausgetauscht.
Und du kannst sehen, wie es ein bisschen zerlässt,
wo es meinen Finger zerlässt, aber es war sicherlich kein Blut.
Aber eines der Dinge, die ich immer höre,
wenn ich einen von diesen sehe,
an einer Konvention, am Saustop-Buch, oder
du siehst Kommentare in YouTube-Videos, wo Leute sagen,
ja, aber sie gehen so langsam mit den Hotdogs.
Also was, wenn du so schnell wie möglich gewinnst?
Wir haben uns entschieden, das auszuprobieren,
indem wir einen Hotdog in den Blatt
so schnell wie möglich werfen.
Wir kalkulierten durch den Framerate, den ich...
Die könnten es auch mit einem Baguette ausprobieren.
Aber ein Baguette leitet nicht so gut, denke ich mal.
Krass! Guck mal, wie schnell das geht!
Ah!
Okay, wie dick ist so eine Wurscht?
So daumendick ungefähr, oder?
So ungefähr daumendick, würde ich sagen,
ist die Wurscht.
Das heißt,
das hätte je nachdem,
das hätte auf jeden Fall
so knapp bis,
also von der Seite,
das hätte schon so weit reingeschnitten,
bis zum Daumennagel ungefähr.
Also die schnellste Variante, ja.
Natürlich,
natürlich sägt keiner so schnell.
Ich meine, so schnell sägt ja keiner.
Du schiebst das ja langsam ran.
Dann hast du wirklich nur einen Kratzer.
Guck dir das an, das ist ziemlich verrückt.
Mit all dem Geschwindigkeit und Inertie
und, weißt du, ich habe durch die Kugel gefolgt,
es hat nur das Hotdog
um eine Achtung geschnitten.
Gegen meinen Finger, das würde nicht so nahe kommen,
bis ich das Knie schiebe.
Um eine Achtung,
du kommst da kaum in die Flasche,
du hast vielleicht ein paar Stücke,
aber du wirst sicher wieder am Arbeiten,
sobald du deine Stücke rauskommst.
Kekona-Einheiten.
Was zum Teufel ist ein Achtel Inch?
Freedom Units.
Okay, was ist ein Achtel Inch?
Inch?
Millimeter.
Drei Millimeter.
Drei Millimeter ist wirklich nicht so viel.
Das ist so ganz knapp am Daumennagel,
so ungefähr.
So oft von der Tiefe her.
Wenn du es direkt in deine Kugel drückst,
wirst du einfach weglaufen mit einem kleinen Dreh.
Oder, was es wirklich zeigt,
wenn du einen großen Kickback hattest,
also wenn du bereits über dein Knie warst,
und es hat einen großen Kickback gemacht
und es hat deine Hand voll mit der Kugel durchgezogen,
wirst du einen kleinen Knick bekommen,
aber deine Finger werden noch einen Tag weiter kämpfen.
Und das ist ziemlich unglaublich.
Aber ich glaube, wo ich wirklich, wirklich beeindruckt war,
bei dem Schuss, den wir gemacht haben,
war die Dato-Aktivierung.
Also, während eine 10-Inch-Kugel 2 Kilo wiegt,
kann eine Dato-Stack 5-8 Kilo wiegen.
Das sind etwa 2,8 bis 4-mal so viele Gs.
Also, ich bin kein Physiker,
aber ihr könnt das für mich in den Kommentaren kalkulieren.
Wenn man die Dato-Aktivierung anschaut,
funktioniert es in der gleichen Weise.
Die Dato-Aktivierung ist aber größer,
weil es mehr Distanz benötigt,
weil es ein kleinerer Blatt ist.
Aber es ist auch breiter,
weil es so viel mehr Kraft benötigt.
In der Tat, diese Kraft war so intensiv,
dass wir etwas auf der Kamera fanden,
dass ich nicht weiß, ob ihr das glaubt.
Das geht echt ultra schnell.
Boah, da zerfetzt die Säge.
Vielleicht wäre in dem Fall eine Schutzbrille gar nicht so schlecht.
Nicht, dass du so ein Ding da noch ins Auge kriegst.
Fingern nicht abgeschnitten, aber Splitter im Auge.
Ja gut, das ist das, was ich gerne sehe.
Ich würde gerne jemanden, der immer seine Sicherheitsglasen trägt,
und sicherlich ein Brille wie die Katz Moses Brille.
Es kann nicht schaden, es zu tragen,
weil es dich von Kicks und so weiter schützt,
aber was wirklich beeindruckend ist,
ist, dass diese Hotdogs aussehen.
Die normalen 10-Inch-Blade-Aktivationen
haben ein bisschen einen Schmuck,
aber die Dato, wenn du 2,8 bis 4-mal die Kraft hast,
aber wirklich kein Schmuck, kein Schmuck.
Ich meine, für mich ist das das Schrecklichste.
Ein Dato-Stack ist schrecklich.
Diese sind in Europa illegal,
für einen Grund, weil sie eine große Masse
von Stahl und Carbide sind, die bei 4.000...
Was ist in Europa illegal?
Dato-Stack ist schrecklich.
Diese sind in Europa illegal,
für einen Grund, weil sie eine große Masse
von Stahl und Carbide sind, die bei 4.000 RPM spinnen
und es ist schwer, sich zu langsam zu machen.
Es ist also nicht etwas, was ich je gesehen habe.
Ich habe noch nie eine Dato-Aktivation gesehen.
Es ist etwas, für das ich super glücklich bin,
jetzt, dass wir das testen können,
dass ich weiß, dass meine Dato-Stack
in der Lage ist, zu funktionieren.
Es ist nicht möglich, dass das Unerwartete
für mich passiert.
Ich mag diese Sachen.
Und es wird für mich wirklich wichtig,
sie so lange wie möglich zu halten.
Wenn du Leute hörst, die sagen,
dass du zu langsam gegangen bist,
oder es gibt einen Design-Fall,
bei dem es vielleicht stoppen kann,
aber deine Hand wird immer noch vermengt werden,
ist das nicht so.
Das ist sehr gut.
Wenn ich mir irgendwann mal eine Säge kaufen sollte,
kaufe ich etwas mit SawStop.
Allerdings kaufe ich mir keine Säge,
weil ich wüsste nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Kostet aber einen Haufen.
Naja, besser Finger dran, als Finger ab.
Ich kaufe mir wahrscheinlich eh keine Säge.
Ich habe da absolut keinen Anwendungszweck
für Kostüme.
Also, das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Essential Tools, Diablo Future,
Emo-Geschichte,
Do-it-yourself-Home-Automation
for Beginners,
Automate your Garage Door.
Oh, das ist
Big Brain Time.
Big Brain, Big Brain.
Ich meine, mein Garage Door muss ich eh nicht
automatisieren, weil mein Garage Door
ist im Prinzip einfach nur
eine Müllhalde.
Eine, eine,
eine,
mehr oder weniger ein Lager, die Garage.
Da steht ja das Auto nicht drin.
Remember killstreaking
Oh komm, wir gucken mal ne Runde.
Wir gucken mal ne Runde Black Ops 1.
Ich habe jetzt echt Bock, wieder
Runde Black Ops 1 zu gucken.
Yo, what is going on guys?
Fortunate here, and today we're gonna be playing
some Black Ops 1, going over all
of the killstreaks in Black Ops 1.
Black Ops 1 was one of my favorite Call of Duties
and it also had some of my favorite
killstreaks. Drop a like if you guys do
enjoy the video, and if you wanna see more
Black Ops 1 content, let me know down in the
comments below.
Also, I wanna know what was
your favorite killstreak of all time.
Hey, da war schon viel Crap dabei, ne?
Sentry Garden zum Beispiel, nie gespielt,
Jam Turret nie gespielt, Mortar Team
auch relativ, Valkyrie Rockets haben
gesackt, Rolling Thunder war jetzt auch
nicht so geil.
Wahrscheinlich spielt es kaum einer.
Galil Silence, beste.
Cannot believe it took me that long to find a game.
You know, the frickin' main menu says
1.7 million people online,
obviously that's a complete hoax.
Oh gosh, close to dying there.
Also the guns in this game,
the guns in this game bring back so many memories too.
Spielst du noch das neue Modern Warfare aktiv?
Ich spiel ab und zu mal Warzone, ja.
Aber sonst gar nicht.
I remember using these things in frickin'
Dirt and Destroy.
Moment, jetzt wo ich das erste XD k.
Moment, Moment.
Kann sich noch irgendjemand an das
Video erinnern?
Fuck, hier.
Kennt das noch jemand
mit dem Fabian am Start?
Lol.
Aufgenommen mit der schlechtesten
Playstation Kamera aller Zeiten.
Ich hab die Bros hingestellt,
weil wir hatten gestern schon mal ein Video aufgenommen
Mit der Silvana zusammen.
Wo ist das RC-Car?
Mit dem flachen Finger?
Ja, Black Ops RC-Car.
Aber das ist eigentlich auch Explosionsgeräusch.
Der sieht ja aus wie 12.
Der Fabian sah halt ewig aus wie,
keine Ahnung, 17, 18.
Mittlerweile
sieht er auch ein bisschen älter aus.
Nee, mach das nicht, das ist übelst dumm.
Meine Katzen haben davor Angst.
Das heißt,
wieso ich sag das?
Die Leute haben ja geschwört, sie haben mich in den
in den Spiegeln gesehen, ne?
Nee.
Excellent driving skills.
Habt ihr noch Kontakt?
Ja, klar, wir kennen uns ja auch schon
voll YouTube Zeug.
Rekt.
Ja, ich hab einen
von Point Blank Range.
Sam Turret, ready for the level.
Sam Turret's been in, what?
Couple games?
I don't know what games this Sam Turret has been in,
but basically it was like a stinger from
Auto Warfare 2.
If you haven't ever used the Sam Turret,
it just shoots down every single killstreak
that goes to the sky.
Übelste Crap Killstreak.
Hat nie jemand mitgenommen.
Oh my gosh.
Das ist ganz einfach,
man muss einfach schneller die Killstreaks kriegen
als der Gegner und wenn man
das nicht schafft, Rage quittet man einfach
aus dem Game.
Bam.
Let's go.
Der war gut.
The napalm strike was actually
very lethal for a 5 killstreak.
It can cut off a certain portion of the map.
The Napalm Strike was nice.
especially in noobs town.
Vor allem gab es immer genug noobs die reingelaufen sind
in das Napalm noch nachträglich.
...and we're going to move up to stronger
and better killstreaks.
One day Im going to have to make a video ranking my favorite Call of Duties.
Like, umm...
Best to worst or something like that.
I feel like a lot of you guys would be interested in my opinion.
I'm also interested in your guys's opinion too.
I'd say ranking the best
Von dem Multiplayer her ist Modern Warfare das mit Abstand schlechteste, also das Neue.
Der Multiplayer ist so für'n Arsch und Warzone hat dem Game krass den Arsch gerettet.
What? Ah, der hat ein Flag Check-It an.
MP ist nur zum Waffe leveln, ja.
Sam Turret, ey. Vor allem den Sam Turret, ne, den musste man ja auch noch aus ner Kiste holen. Das war so'n richtiger Crap-Killstreak.
Man konnte die aber rerollen, ganz am Anfang war das OP. Also man konnte, ähm, ich überleg grad, was das war, Sam Turret, sonstwas, und du hast dann diesen Reroll, ähm, mitgenommen und da konntest du den Sam Turret rerollen zu irgendwie nem Chopper Gunner oder so.
Das war schon cool.
Aber ansonsten...
... war das, ähm, hast du das nicht mitgenommen.
Weg, sprayen, pray. Moin von der Arbeit.
Moin, Krischpe.
Warum musst du arbeiten, sonntags?
Nicht schlecht. Wir werden weiter mit dem nächsten Set von Killstreaks hier.
Sobald ich nicht mehr Jungle spielen wollte, war das das, worauf wir gezwungen sind. Ich werde nicht aus diesem Lobby zurück, weil Gott weiß, ob wir noch einen finden werden.
Auch war auf Poggers Waffe. Wobei ich ja sagen muss, Farmers, ähm, Farmers und Aweia, mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Aber die haben... das war... ich überleg grad, was hab ich... äh, die Kommando, Galil Silenced und Farmers, beste.
Ammos, weil ich glaube, dass es nur so ein oder zwei gute waren.
Einer von denen war Tiger, wie Fall-Ammo.
Der andere war... ich weiß es gar nicht.
Jedenfalls, wir gehen weiter mit dem Morderteam, Valkyrie-Rockets und ich glaube...
Oh, Valkyrie-Rockets waren so mies schlecht.
Wir werden jetzt auf die Century-Gun drücken, weil wir natürlich Century-Gun und ein paar andere Call-Duties gesehen haben.
Und, äh, es ist ein 6er-Killstreak wie das Morderteam. Und ich würde lieber das Morderteam verwenden.
Und was die Waffenwahl betrifft, haben wir den Ogg.
Arbeiten durch, wir haben sehr viel Arbeit, krass.
Ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Ja, also, Mörser-Strike war in COD 5 natürlich ganz gut, weil es das einzige Killstreak, den es gab.
Aber hier war das mega Sack.
Die Valkyrie-Rockets waren auch crap.
Das Ding ging.
Warum hat man nochmal Weise nicht mehr?
Das einzig Gute an dem Killstreak war, dass er durch Dächer ging.
Boah!
Nice!
Es war aber halt, wenn du so willst, OP, dass du mit dem Napalm-Strike mehr oder weniger das Gleiche hingekriegt hast.
Vor allem, dass die aus der Kiste kommen, ist kacke. Hätte man die direkt auslösen können, wäre besser gewesen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass viele Leute die Valkyrie-Rockets benutzen, weil sie schwer zu kontrollieren sind.
Die sind Müll.
Die sind übelst Müll.
Erstmal hoch und dann muss man runterfliegen, genau.
Bam!
Oh, ich habe ein Doppel aus dem. Los geht's!
Okay, das ist selten.
Oh, ich habe noch einen Schuss hier.
Oh.
Wir werden verachten, dass wir das nicht gesehen haben.
Die Valkyrie-Rockets sind wahrscheinlich nicht wert für den 7-Kill-Streak.
Ich kann dir das sagen.
Das stimmt.
Die waren Müll.
Die funktionieren wirklich gut.
5 Jungs.
Oh, er ist noch da oben.
Das war mein Glück.
Ich bin hier rumgerannt, um einen Claymore runter zu legen.
Ein weiteres Motor-Team.
Okay, das ist schwer ohne einen UAV.
Ich bin fertig.
I-owan what?
Ja!
Ich habe eine Frage, wie das zählt.
Ich glaube, ich schreibe es an die Leute.
Ja, das ist gut.
Es geht auf jeden Fall um das Wichtigste.
Schreibe ich das jetzt?
Ja.
Das muss ich halt wissen.
Ich habe das auch gesagt.
Und jetzt, es geht nicht mehr so um das Wichtigste.
Ich muss es nicht ausdrücken.
Ich habe das schon gesagt.
Da kann ich das nachher anklopfen.
Eben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie es nicht so kannten.
Ich kann es ja noch eines sagen.
Ich habe es noch nicht gesagt.
Es ist klar.
Aber das ist ja total umsonst, dass es so etwas passiert.
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen ist noch da, die das gucken, aber der Hype ist ganz schnell wieder weg gewesen.
Es gab viele Gaming-Hypes, wo auch eine Portion davon überlebt hat, aber es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen,
dass wenn ein neues, gutes Battlefield kommt oder ein neues, gutes Call of Duty mit ordentlichem Multiplayer,
dass das auch viele Leute spielen werden.
Ach, das war der Mörser.
Zombie-Games, Survival-Geschichten, Crafting-Sachen, alles hat irgendwo ein bisschen überlebt, aber nicht in der Masse.
Nach 200 Stunden hat sein Game... Nö, finde ich nicht.
Gute Spiele kannst du viel länger spielen.
Also, welche mit einem ordentlichen Endgame, ja.
Guckt euch mal Leute an, wie viele Leute, wie viel, wie viel, wie lange haben Leute CS gespielt?
Tausende Stunden. 200 Stunden ist ja nix.
Ich mein, 200 Stunden für ein Singleplayer-Spiel, für irgendwie so eine Art, äh, sag mal so,
wenn du 200 Stunden hast, jetzt sag mal in Borderlands oder so, okay, dann ist was anderes, ja.
Stellsort, 10 Monate, Dankeschön. Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also, ich glaube ja, dass das neue Call of Duty gar kein Battle Royale beinhalten wird.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Warzone weiter betreiben, parallel,
und, ähm, das nächste Call of Duty Multiplayer-only wird.
Also, mit Kampagne diesmal. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Multiplayer-only, ohne Battle Royale.
Ich kann mir nicht... Ich fände es komisch, wenn die nach dem Riesenerfolg...
...und den dauerhaft anhaltenden, hohen Spielzahlen von Warzone das, äh, rausnehmen.
Vielleicht wird's... Vielleicht kriegt's ein Refresh...
...mit, äh, Cold War. Vielleicht kriegt's mit Cold War ne neue Map, oder so.
Mal gucken. Bin mal gespannt, wie sie das machen.
Genau, das glaub ich auch. Das neue Call of Duty kriegt Kampagne-Zombie-Modus-Multiplayer.
Und Warzone wird wahrscheinlich parallel weiter betrieben.
Vielleicht gibt's ne neue Map.
Es gibt bestimmt...
Es gibt bestimmt auch...
Guck mal, Warzone hat so nen Potential, auch mit nem neuen Call of Duty.
Du kannst die Charaktere aus der Singleplayer reinbringen.
Du kannst Waffen aus dem anderen Call of Duty bringen.
Es gibt doch überhaupt keinen Grund, warum das an Modern Warfare gebunden sein sollte.
Die lassen einfach den Modern Warfare-Part da sterben von.
Das ist einfach nur noch Call of Duty Warzone.
Ja, 200 Stunden ist für nen Spiel schon lang.
Aber halt nicht für die Ultra-Crime-Games, ne?
Aber insgesamt...
So ne Durchschnittsgröße ist schon lang.
BÄÄM!
Alter, ich hab glaub ich mit den Valkyrie-Rockets in gesamten Spielzeiten nicht so viel Kills gemacht, wie in einem Game hier grade.
Nice, dude.
Making progress with the Valkyrie-Rockets.
Let's go.
And there we go. Final kill with the M1911s again.
37 and 8. Wow, that game went significantly better.
We're gonna move on to the better killstreaks.
Ich hab noch ein paar Black Ops 1-Gameplays, die ich schon im halben Jahr erspiele.
Oh!
Black Ops 1.
Das ist Dings hier.
Das ist Dings hier. Das ist Dings hier.
Die, die X-Dings.
Oh, wie hieß die Waffe? X11 oder so, ne?
I'm obviously missing the gunship.
I think I'll get some spare gameplay with that, so it's not left alone.
G11, nicht X11, G11.
I love the G11 too.
The G11 was like 4 round burst, I think.
And so powerful.
Ja, das war richtig gut, das Ding.
We're dead.
Das war, ich glaube, es gab ja zwei Burst-Waffen, ne?
Es gab die...
Und die M16.
Und ich glaube, die M16...
Die M16 hat ein bisschen weniger Damage gemacht als die G11, deswegen...
Ich glaube, das eine hat irgendwie 35 und das andere hat 40 gemacht.
Also sprich, das eine war 3er-Burst-Kill und das andere war...
Nicht Kill...
Ach, irgendwie komisch war es.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Aber Silence, Galil, Kommando und Pharma ist besser.
I don't want to be a window-camper.
I kinda want to, because it might be the easiest way to get my kills.
Erstmal schön ins Duke-Town-House campen.
Excellent.
Dead.
Aber wisst ihr...
Wisst ihr, was man hier an Duke-Town gut sieht?
So scheiße ich Duke-Town fand.
Ich weiß, dass Duke-Town viele Fans hatte.
Ich mein, es wurde nicht umsonst dreimal remaked.
So scheiße ich Duke-Town fand.
Man sieht, dass es irgendwie in Black Ops 1 auch noch halbwegs predictable war, wo was herkommt.
Stellt euch diese Map in Modern Warfare vor.
In Modern Warfare spawnt jetzt hier auf dem Balkon einer und der killt alle drei.
Total random.
I appreciate that.
Und in Modern Warfare...
Hättest du hier nen Headclitch-Spot, da nen Headclitch-Spot, da noch nen Fenster im Auto,
hier nen Headclitch-Spot, hier nen Leiter obendrauf, hier nen Leiter obendrauf, hier
hinten könntest du nochmal im Kreis gehen, da aufs Dach und hier oben aufs Dach könntest
du auch rein spawnen.
So.
Das...
So würde Duke-Town in Modern Warfare aussehen.
Und da noch...
Und da noch ein Fenster.
Da noch ein Fenster, wo du dich auflegen und Headclitchen kannst.
Doch, direkt über ihn.
Ah, bester...
Bester Killstreak in der gesamten History of hier...
Dieser Spieleserie.
Blackbird.
Eigentlich viel zu OP, wenn man es genau nimmt, aber beste, beste.
Also gerade die Kombi mit Attack-Dogs war halt übelst geil.
Kramautzu!
Oh, ah, der hat Highkills nix gespielt.
Ey.
아, اbalance auf ツ
security
Sie haben auch alle im Haus gecampt wahrscheinlich.
It white übrigens nä, Pokémonired.
Anyway...
shooting is pretty good.
Die wollten ihn direkt runter geiern.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wie sie reinspawnen.
Lull.
Das war schon OP, ne?
Gerade auf Nuketown.
Ja, Gunship habe ich sehr selten gespielt, weil das eigentlich ziemlich cool war mit
Selbstkontrollieren und den Raketen.
Gunship war halt das Problem, dass du zwei Kills mehr gebraucht hast.
Alter, blinde, oh, blinde Gegner.
Oh, oh, oh.
Was ist das?
KS.
Chopper, also in MW2 kann man sich darüber streiten, ob, äh, Moment.
Oh mein Gott.
Oder da war ein Chopper besser, kommt ein bisschen auf die Map an.
Oh.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Oh mein Gott.
In MW2 war alles okay, ja das stimmt schon. MW2 ist auch so extrem schnell gestorben.
Das hatte auch Raketen, das Ding, ne? Nein! Oh!
Das Ding hatte auch Raketen, glaube. Ja, genau.
Stimmt, Sentry Gun, das Ding hat auch kaum einer. Der Fabian hat das immer, immer gespielt,
wo ich mich bis heute frage, warum? In Warzone ist auch viel OP. Ja, ich habe gehört, die
neue Fifty Cal Sniper killt nicht in One-Hit. Auf den Kopf.
Ja, ich habe gehört, die neue Fifty Cal Sniper killt nicht in One-Hit. Auf den Kopf.
Also die Hälfte der Killstreaks waren es, in Black Ops 1, die haben gesuckt. Aber die
andere Hälfte war geil und S.A.S.F. und T1, huge. Ne, Moab war nicht in Black Ops. Moab
war in, ne Ghosts war Camp Strike, Moab war in MW3. Da ist die, da ist die! Moab! Moab!
Da ist sie Moab. Da ist sie Moab. Da ist sie Moab.
Da ist sie Moab. Da ist sie Moab.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
Der hat einen Lego-Kran gebaut.
Was ist denn das? Das geht mit den Leuten wieder ab.
Okay, das hat ein bisschen gedauert, glaube ich.
Vor allem, wie der einfach mal einen Lego-Kran im Wohnzimmer stehen hat.
Kann man den jetzt sogar kaufen?
Kann man das?
Ich dachte, das ist irgendein selbstgebildetes Ding.
Nee, oder?
Aber übelst nice.
Nicht, dass man damit was anfangen könnte, aber cool ist das trotzdem.
Trotzdem.
Bis der einfach einen Kran im Wohnzimmer stehen hat.
Krass.
Also, Lego-Kran.
Das ist nicht das viel zu advanced hier.
Aber ist doch nice, ey.
Ist doch nice.
Einfach mal einen Kran aus Lego.
Richtig Poggers.
Und man sieht, wie groß das Ding ist.
Hier hat er einen Sessel stehen.
Und daneben steckt der Kran.
Das Ding ist zwei Meter hoch oder so.
Und ich kann den Stuhl hochheben.
Also, da hat er bestimmt lang dran gebaut.
Vorbei.
Heftig.
Sieben Meter.
Moment.
What the fuck?
Aber hier hinten muss der ein richtig fettes Gewicht dran haben, dass das nicht umkippt.
Einfach einen sieben Meter Lego-Kran.
Und dann...
Alter.
Oh.
Voll was im Hals, ey.
Das ist so hoch wie das Haus fast.
Was für ein Shit.
Aber da hat er eine Weile dran gebastelt.
Das ist nicht von heute auf morgen fertig.
Oh.
Immerhin.
Es kann ein Smartphone hochheben.
Aber viel mehr musste ich ja überlegen.
Wenn das Ding sieben Meter lang ist und vorne noch was zusätzlich hochhebt, das zieht halt
ganz schön.
Und sogar die...
Das ist Big Brain.
Mit dem Handy filmen, wie es hochfährt.
Und jetzt erst mal droppen.
Bring mal das Smartphone hoch.
Genau.
Erst mal Kran ausfahren.
Guck mal, das kann er wirklich jetzt auf den Balkon legen.
Ah, der ist gar nicht mehr dran.
Und er kann sogar dabei fahren.
Massive.
Guck mal, wie geil ist das.
Huge.
Also was...
Was die Leute da alles bauen.
Übelst heftig.
What happens when you order a 29...
Wenn man 29 Dollar Laptop auf Facebook besucht?
Wahrscheinlich scam, würde ich sagen.
Here's an ad I keep seeing crop up on various platforms advertising a pocket-sized Windows
laptop.
The product shown in the video is real, but the deal is a scam.
Let's investigate.
Here's an ad I keep seeing crop up on various platforms advertising a pocket-sized Windows
laptop.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Scammers? Facebook? Ads?
Ha, ha, ha.
Ja.
Das stimmt schon.
Ich kann es auch schwer erkennen.
Ich finde, der Shop sieht tatsächlich richtig nach so einem Shop aus,
der nur aufgesetzt wurde zum Scammen.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, woran man das festmacht.
Vielleicht hier unten ein bisschen.
Auch, dass es so nach einem 0815-Standard-Template aussieht,
dass die Schrift hier oben übelst sackt.
Es ist schwierig zu erkennen,
aber so das Gesamtbild sieht irgendwie nach Scam-Shop aus.
Ja, das haben sie immer gerne.
Ihr wisst ja auch, nur heute kriegt ihr den kostenlosen Kurs,
wie ihr in einer Woche Millionär werdet.
Morgen ist das Ganze nicht mehr kostenlos.
Also jetzt anmelden und jetzt der WhatsApp-Gruppe joinen.
Ja, das ist nicht so die Idee.
Ja.
Der bessere Variante!
Er.
Ja.
Checking their policies, I found that they promised to ship all orders within 24 hours, so I waited 24 hours.
Nothing changed. It said the order was still awaiting shipment, so I emailed their inquiries address to innocently ask when my order would ship.
Das riecht schon ganz hart nach...
You've got to make it.
...my order would ship.
They told me to please keep calm and that they had shipped my order.
They gave me a tracking number, which when I tried to trace it, didn't resolve to anything.
Die Mail sieht auch so übelst zusammen copy-pasted aus.
Guck mal, please don't worry.
Also, please don't worry. Klingt nach legit customer service.
Einen Tag oder zwei später bekam ich ein Parzell. Das Tracking-Nummer war das, was sie mir gegeben haben.
Oh, da kam was an. Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
... mein Mini-Laptop, zum Schluss.
Ich öffnete das Parzell. Innerlich waren zwei Sachen drin.
Ein Paar sehr günstige Augenbrauen und eine einzigartige klinische Gesichtsmaske.
Das sieht so aus, als hätte jemand es handeln müssen, um es in diese individuelle Tasche zu packen.
Es wäre also eine extrem schlechte Idee, das auf deinen Gesicht zu packen.
Was? Das ist ja komplett unrelated.
Ich habe jetzt gedacht, die hätten nämlich so Plastik...
... in die Box geschickt oder so.
... und die ganze Clothing-In-Joy-Shop-Invice-Store wäre weg.
Ich denke, das ganze ist eine Schande, weil meine Erfahrung mit Ads auf sozialen Plattformen so beschädigt ist, dass meine Ansicht auf Ads...
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin noch nie auf die Idee gekommen, über irgendeine Werbung, sei es YouTube, Facebook, Twitter, Ads, was auch immer, was zu kaufen.
Noch nie. Ohne Scheiß, noch nie.
Das Einzige, was mich dazu gebracht hat, ist vielleicht irgendein Review-Video von Leuten.
Die ich gerne gucke auf YouTube.
Beispielsweise, wenn ich irgendein Video gesehen habe, da wurden irgendwelche Werkzeug-Geschichten gezeigt, die mir gefallen haben.
Dann habe ich etwas bestellt.
Aber ich bestelle eigentlich nie über Werbe-Ads.
Nie.
Auch nicht auf Google, also ich bestelle nie über Ads.
Ein Facebook ist es dem egal.
Meine Aufmerksamkeit ist, dass das Produkt den Kunden verkauft wird.
Also, das ist das, was passiert, wenn du etwas für mich bestellst.
Weißt du, eine Sache, die ich nicht verstehe bei dieser Werbe-Geschichte?
Twitch, YouTube, die sind immer dabei, dass ihre Content-Creator, die sollen alle, also vor allem die Aushängeschilder, die sollen alle weißer als weiß sein.
Also, ich meine damit weiße Weste.
Also, ich meine jetzt nicht...
Ihr wisst, ne?
Bevor jetzt wieder irgendeiner ankommt.
Die sollen alle reiner als rein, könnte man sagen, sein.
Also sprich, die sollen keinerlei in keinerlei Skandale verwickelt sein und in keinerlei...
Die sollen wirklich so engelsgleich, so irgendwie Vorzeigeleute sein, ja?
So Role Models, also die Aushänge Content-Creator.
So, also sprich, Twitch und YouTube, die stellen so hohe Anforderungen quasi an ihre Aushänge Content.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben sie die übelste Scam-Shady-Werbung am Start.
Da frage ich mich, was schadet der Reputation einer Plattform mehr?
Ehm, einen Content-Creator, der ab und zu mal das falsche Wort verwendet, weil er gerade irgendwie in Action ist und nicht richtig aufpasst.
Oder Scammers-Shady-Werbung.
Also, ich bevorzuge authentische Content-Creator, die sich auch mal verplappern dürfen.
Mehr als...
Überall nur korrekte...
Leute.
Und wenn ich merke, dass der Content-Creator ein Depp ist, dann gucke ich ihn halt nicht.
Raid Shadow Legends, genau.
More Videos like this, okay.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch?
Wie Stumpway sich selbst zerstört.
Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt?
Ich frage mich, warum hat mir YouTube das heute vorgeschlagen?
Ich habe... Manchmal komme ich mir übelst verfolgt vor, ne?
Wir haben gestern im Stream nach einem Subway geguckt.
Und heute kriege ich Subway-Videos empfohlen.
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Hm.
Veilor und Netcode-Analyse.
Overclocking Wunder.
Battlefield 4 Plays.
How to Twitch Chat, PogChamp.
How to Twitch Chat, Forehead.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Das Chat...
Wir müssen uns heute mal ein bisschen weiterbilden.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Ne, das andere haben wir geguckt.
Die Pipo-Emotes haben wir schon geguckt.
Alright, alright.
Quiet down, quiet down.
Okay.
Who threw that?
Okay, nochmal.
So.
Drip in.
Hm. Hm.
Ist richtig gut gemacht.
Quiet down, quiet down.
Okay.
Who threw that?
Was it you?
You are always causing trouble in this classroom.
I swear if it was you, you are out of here.
Do you hear me?
On my shoulder.
Anyways.
I will let the Culper go this time.
As our lesson today has a lot to do with just getting over things.
First of all, I wanna welcome you all back.
And if you missed the first lesson, I highly recommend you listen.
I highly recommend you look at a classmates notes.
Because I am not going to do any review of the last class.
And if you're lost, that is on you.
Without further ado, today let's take a look at another staple base Twitch emote.
Forehead.
And it's FFZ and better TTV variants.
First off, let's look at Forehead, Foreheader and Foreheat.
Foreheader.
These three emotes plus the base Forehead emote all have for the most part the same meaning.
It's just important you understand the context in which they're being used.
Not to follow more...
Well, how do I say this?
More dumbed down tutorials, for lack of kind of words.
You might be under the impression that Forehead is just used as a reaction to a joke.
Which to some extent is true.
But I genuinely don't think I've ever seen the emote as a replacement to LOL or LOLW.
Or any other laughing emote.
Also, Forehead...
Für mich...
Also, ich verwende Forehead relativ selten.
Wenn was lustig ist, mach ich eigentlich in der Regel LOL, kek, weh, LOL, weh, was auch immer.
Forehead ist eher sowas...
Ähm...
Oh, wie soll man das beschreiben?
Wenn irgendwas...
...nicht ganz so lustig ist, wie es eigentlich sein sollte.
Ja, wenn irgendwas nicht ganz so lustig ist, wie es sein sollte.
Oder wenn einer halt...
...was sagt...
...was total offensichtlich ist...
...und halt total einfach klingt.
So nach dem Motto, mein PC, äh, keine Ahnung, mein Spiel ruckelt...
...und dann so nach dem Motto, einfach 5000 Euro PC kaufen, Forehead.
Oder so.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, irgendwas in der Richtung, ja.
Ist ja was situationsabhängig.
Ich...
Ich kann schlecht beschreiben, ähm, wann ich welche Emotes verwende.
Das ist so impulsiv, ja.
Oder intuitiv.
So, wenn ich was sehe, kommt das passende Emote quasi automatisch aus meiner Hand getippt.
These four emotes main uses are as follows.
What?
Was war das?
The replacement to LOL or LOLW.
Or any other laughing emote for that matter.
These four emotes main uses are as follows.
Is something quite difficult being oversimplified?
And the starting word of their explanation was the word just?
Well, all you have to do is just type just forehead or any other variant you wish.
These emotes are used extremely sarcastically...
...and are meant to highlight the ridiculousness of downplaying something difficult...
...as if it was just easy as breathing.
For example, if your favorite Fortnite-Streamer myth is cranking those fat 90s...
...and you ask him, how can you also crank a gargantuan 90...
...hoping he'll respond with some quick and easy tips to practice them...
...but his response is, man, I'd just do it.
The second you hear that just come from his mouth...
...is the perfect time to initiate a just forehead spam.
But knowing myths chat, you're probably gonna be like one out of three people...
...who actually know how to type the emote out in the first place.
But that's why you all are here.
It's our learning process.
And I can guarantee you, you'll master the language of Genshin.
You'll actually even know how to type the emote out in the first place.
But that's why you all are here.
It's our learning process.
And I can guarantee you, you'll master the language of Twitch...
...and culture of the Twitch-Chat sooner than later.
The other main use for these emotes is...
...and to be honest, I believe this is the use that I see the most for this set of variants...
...is if a joke is being told that, well, wasn't really funny in the first place...
...but a streamer or whoever the streamer is with starts to laugh uncontrollably...
...for seemingly no reason...
...is when these variants shine.
No text is needed, just the emotes themselves are enough to get the message through.
The main purpose is to sarcastically make fun of the person's laugh...
...and for the most part the laugh in question is always to some degree...
...a loud or obnoxious chuckle.
Maybe throw in some dry heaving...
Perfect laugh for a forehead spam.
These emotes are the most smart-ass and sarcastic emotes as you can get...
...well, besides Pepe Laugh, but we'll get there another time.
Now that we covered the three main variants...
...there is also an emote that was birthed because of those...
...the emote that we're talking about...
...this emote's earliest review was around 2017...
...when the game Comedy Night was the new early access scam game to hit the market...
...allowing people to stream comedy with their favorite streamer...
...thus allowing people to stream comedy with their favorite streamer...
...dus allowing people to stream comedy without any special permission to happen.
How is somebody harmless?
Just get a house.
Thank you.
So dumb, Allah.
...and it's only used when the words just get a house are said...
...or some variation of the words...
...but truthfully it's always funny to see a four-house spam in chat...
...because it is truly so rare.
The next two emotes we'll cover today are almost polar opposites to each other.
Let's check out Three Head and Five Head.
Starting out with Three Head.
Oi.
was originally created to spam whenever someone
with a very strong British accent was
on screen. But also immediately after it
was created, it got turned into an E-Mail to spam
anytime a British person
or anything British related is caught on screen.
So using this E-Mail is very self-explanatory.
See someone even remotely British or in some
cases, they could even be Australian,
because chat can't tell the difference between two accents.
Be ready to unleash the power
of your almighty...
Und shoutout to all my three head viewers watching this video.
I'll be on FIFA later, so you boys better
hop on.
Excellent kommt jetzt.
Das hört sich schon so an.
Exquisite. Excellent.
Moving on to the most
exquisite E-Mail on Twitch.TV
Let's talk about 5Head.
Whether an extremely...
Das Intro ist zu geil.
Exquisite.
Moving on to the most exquisite E-Mail on Twitch.TV
Let's talk about 5Head.
Whether an extremely
high-end...
Excellent.
Someone smart is explaining something.
But most people want to do good and I think
I'm one of those people.
Where did you get that idea?
Or a word with more than four syllables
is said. Be ready to witness
the barrage of 5Head spam.
Usually accompanied with a wine glass
and the word exquisite...
Excellent. Exquisite geht auch her.
...something intelligent is happening or happening.
Bestes E-Mail.
Das ist ja mein absolutes Lieblings E-Mail auf ganz Twitch.
...is used sarcastically when a streamer
is pretending to say something intelligent. Das ist ja mein absolutes Lieblings E-Mail auf ganz Twitch.
...ist sarcastically when a streamer ist pretending to say something intelligent.
...sort of a...
...property...
...where they...
...if the frequencies...
Was muss ich mir eigentlich holen um die E-Mails statt
zu sehen? Moment, das ist eine Bildungslücke...
...die müssen wir schließen.
Es gibt zwei Sachen. Das da...
...äh...
...das da oder...
...das da...
...die zwei Sachen. Also eins der beiden
Browser E-Mails musst du holen.
Ich empfehle dir das da, weil ich finde es hat...
...mehr Funktion.
Das Browser E-Mail oder das. Mittlerweile
können beide die E-Mails der jeweils
anderen. Auf dem Handy bist
du gearscht, das stimmt. Es sei denn, du hast
ein Android und verwendest irgendeinen alternativen
Client. Aber ich habe auch nur noch
FFZ. FFZ hat jetzt das letzte
Feature eingebaut, was ich vermisst habe
von bei der Twitch TV, nämlich die Chat History.
Wenn du
FFZ installiert hast und die E-Mails nicht siehst,
musst du in die FFZ
Settings gehen, einmal
GIF E-Mails anmachen,
und das
Häkchen dran machen, dass du bei der Twitch
TV E-Mails haben möchtest.
Ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt, ich kann das im Moment.
Wir machen das jetzt.
Also.
Chat.
So.
Ich habe es ja hier installiert.
FFZ.
Dann müsst ihr auf Settings
FFZ Control Center
Queue Chat.
Genau. So.
Und dann gibt es hier zur Auswahl...
Ich werde es mal größer machen, wenn das irgendwie...
Ob man das nicht mal ordentlich resizen...
So.
Dann geht ihr auf bei der Twitch TV E-Mails
hier bei Addons. Kann man ein Häkchen rein machen.
Und vor allem
Animated GIF E-Mails.
Sollte ja ein Bild sein.
Genau so sollte das aussehen.
Dazu musst du bei Addons
bei der Twitch TV E-Mails anmachen.
Bei der Twitch TV E-Mails musst du unter
Addons einschalten.
Und man sollte
auch die Animated Emotes anmachen.
Ja. Also.
Was haben wir für Animated Emote?
Smart.
Achso. Ich kann ja hier gar nichts schreiben.
Weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Also Too Smart haben wir zum Beispiel. Animiert.
So.
Das musst du anschalten.
Und...
Im Prinzip war es das.
Kannst du hier oben auch suchen.
Animated Emotes.
Kannst du relativ viel machen.
Das wichtigste ist, dass du bei der Twitch...
unter Addons
bei der Twitch TV E-Mails
einschaltest.
Und enablest.
Unter Addons bei der Twitch TV E-Mails enabeln.
Und dann einschaltest.
Wie bist du auf das
gekommen, wo du gerade bist?
Hier unten auf das Rad und dann auf
Franka Face Z
Control Center.
Wobei es ist ja eigentlich eher Franka Faces
Franka Z
Und dann gehst du auf Addons.
Machst bei der Twitch TV E-Mails an.
Und in den Settings von bei der Twitch TV E-Mails
machst du alles an.
Global E-Mails, Pro E-Mails, Channel E-Mails.
Alle E-Mails.
Und wenn du das hier anmachst, dann hast du auch das hier
wird dann zu einem E-Mail.
Macht mal einer.
Das man es gerade sieht.
Wobei ich kann es ja selbst machen auf meinem Vorschau Bildschirm.
Das wird dann auch zu einem E-Mail.
Einfach alles anmachen und GIF E-Mails enablen.
Wenn man GIF E-Mails enabelt hat,
kann man das dann verwenden.
Exquisite.
Five Head kann man dann verwenden.
Wenn ihr noch was sehen wollt, fragt mich.
Mit Twitch E-Mails kenne ich mich mittlerweile aus.
Ups.
Danke es funktioniert
finally.
Exquisite.
Ah yes.
Also ich kenne das mit zwei Sachen.
Einmal Exquisite.
Das ist auch sehr beliebt.
Wubbles, der Kommentator.
Acht Monate, danke schon.
Exquisite Subscription.
Ah yes.
Indeed.
Alles klar.
Ah yes.
Genau.
Also.
Ah yes.
Precisely.
And of course.
You will be the best way to witness this E-Mail in its raw form.
The next two E-Mails are also interchangeable with each other.
With one just being a W version of the prior.
Let's take a look at 4weird and 4weirdW.
Verwend ich nicht.
And of course my came and comedic take on Weirdchamp.
This E-Mail has a very niche community.
You will notice this E-Mail has a lot of use in E-Robz,
who is the younger brother to that one League of Legends addict.
I forgot his name though.
Anyways.
The E-Mail has a lot of use in this channel.
Verwend ich nicht.
And a whole little subsection of streamers as well.
It's effectively replaced Weirdchamp for a lot of those streamers,
which is understandable.
As 4weird is genuinely
4weird? Ne.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Using this E-Mail is very similar to Weirdchamp,
but it's more often focused at the streamer
more than anything else.
This E-Mail is quite popular, but you're not going to see it everywhere,
as it's only enabled in around 4200 channels.
Heading over to LRobzChannel
is probably your best bet to see this E-Mail live and in action.
And the last E-Mail that will be covered today
is 4shrug.
Was? Hab ich noch nie gesehen.
This E-Mail is used,
when even the all knowing Twitch chat
doesn't even have the answer to the question a streamer is asking.
Hab ich noch nie gesehen.
99% of the cases that the question is asked,
it usually stems from a streamer either playing a brand new game
or a random early access game
that no one's heard of at all.
And well in turn,
the streamer is met with a barrage of 4shrug spammers.
Just like the 4house E-Mail,
this E-Mail is quite situational,
but it's still very easy to understand and master.
Okay class, don't forget to bring your notebooks next lesson
if you forgot today.
And it's a big one that will span two classes.
So please bring your notebook and please be prepared.
Ey ey, das Video hat mir gefallen.
Ich will jetzt noch lernen how to Pogchamp.
Hey you, yeah you.
Does mindlessly typing emails into a chat sound like fun to you?
Er meint uns, Chat.
Er meint uns.
Hey you, yeah you.
Wir werden angesprochen.
Er redet mit uns.
Does mindlessly typing emails into a chat sound like fun to you?
Wolltest du fast komplett verlieren,
was auch immer du im sozialen Leben hattest?
Wie ist es, dein Gehirn auszuschalten
und eine massive Hive-Mind zu werden?
Wenn du ein Ja zu all diesen Fragen antwortest,
oh Mann, oh Mann, habe ich dir etwas zu zeigen.
Twitch-Chat.
Jetzt sagst du wahrscheinlich,
Twitch, ist das nicht der Website, wo du Millionen bezahlt wirst?
Don't, don't Pog yet.
Top Chef für 10 Stunden am Tag?
Und dazu mein guter Mann,
all I have to say is,
That's pretty true.
Twitch ist so ein wunderschönes Land,
voll von wunderschönen Leuten,
die so eine starke Leidenschaft für Streaming haben,
in ihrer rauchen Form.
Und es ist egal, wie gebrochen du bist.
Wenn du Zeit hast, Twitch zu schauen,
hast du 10 Dollar.
Neue Talent poppen jeden Tag auf.
Was?
Streaming in ihrer rauchen Form.
Und es ist egal, wie gebrochen du bist.
Wenn du Zeit hast, Twitch zu schauen,
hast du 10 Dollar.
Neue Talent poppen jeden Tag auf.
Was?
Streaming in ihrer rauchen Form.
Und es ist egal, wie gebrochen du bist.
Und so dumms klingt, das ist das Beste an Twitch.
Und das ist, warum keine andere Streaming-Plattform an Twitch reinkommt.
Damit kann ich mich identifizieren.
Oh, das Reh ist da!
Das ist ja huge Twitch-Education.
Exquisite.
Das stimmt wohl.
Poki-W-Wörtchen-Check.
Okay.
Es stimmt wohl.
Die höchste Variante.
Denn manche Leute sind sich auf die Straßen gezogen und ihnen denpochiert.
Ich weiss, ich werde einen Tag er aber sehen, um dieses Ding in meinem Steck zu finden.
Also, manche Leute sind sich auf die Straßen gezogen und ihnen denpochiert.
Also, mal weggehen?
ickerer Dockerkauba-F expenditure.
Klimawandel.
Und das kann ich nur beweisen.
Niemals Credit.
Keineusive Plan.
Diese dass
Genderf cap bat Detour ja nichtим wasled präsentiert.
Jer freut mich es.
Das E-Mote war sehr populär im Jahr 2018, gerade als Fortnite an seinem Peak war.
Also mit einer Waffe von Kindern, die sich an Twitch rutschen, um ihre Primes an Ninja zu werfen,
hat Twitch viel neuen Traffic erholt.
Und irgendwo in diesem Chat, war Poggers, der von der ganzen Fortnite-Community gezwungen wurde,
immer die E-Mote zu verbreiten und es zu verringern,
und es zu spammen, wenn Fortnite oder TikTok erwähnt wird.
Im Grunde genommen, alles Neue und Trendige, das auch kinderfreundlich ist,
ist, wenn Poggers das ideale E-Mote ist, um zu spammen und zu chatten.
Jetzt können wir nur einen Moment des Silenzes für unseren verfluchten Freund, Poggers.
Alright, enough of that.
So selten ist Poggers jetzt auch nicht.
Both of these E-Motes mean virtually the same thing.
There's just two to add some spice to the spam.
Ich bevorzuge Pog-like-this.
These E-Motes replaced Poggers around 2018.
Pog-like-this und Pog.
Nothing cool or crazy happens, just like PogChamp.
But there are some alternative uses that I'll just touch on.
Is a streamer telling a story you don't care about, and you don't want to cool story-bob him?
Instead, try doing weird.
You don't care, Pog.
Is something crazy happening that you really don't understand?
Well, in that case, a question mark Pog-Spam is exactly what you need.
I've also seen this E-Mote used to replace the Wide People Happy Spam in some rare cases,
when a Death Wide People Happy Spam is being commenced.
That is very, very few and far between.
I wouldn't recommend doing it, because it really doesn't make too much sense.
But if you do do it, just be prepared for all the Wide People Happiers to barrage you
and ultimately sacrifice you to their overlords.
Satan.
All in all, these variants are very straightforward, and don't really require much explaining.
They have their purpose to serve, and they serve it well.
Moving on, let's take a look at OK Champ, and everyone's favorite E-Mote, Weird Champ.
So, let's start out with OK Champ.
This E-Mote is used to, well, let the streamer know that everything is okay.
Although a lot of this E-Mote's use is used to show appreciation to someone if they do something commendable.
Usually paired with a thumbs up E-Moji, you can also see this E-Mote spam to show support of another person who is on stream.
But isn't the streamer.
I would use GreekGodX as an example, but this isn't 2017.
So instead, an example that can be used is if xQc is live, and everyone's favorite piglet, Zoyle, is invited to play some games.
For the most part, you'll see chat spam Zoyle, OK Champ, thumbs up E-Moji.
But OK Champ is generally used in a very positive manner, and an OK Champ spam...
Look, I haven't seen an XQC in a while, I have no idea who that is.
...to see.
But for this next E-Mote, I'm not too sure what to say about.
Weird Champ is quite a controversial E-Mote.
And I'll probably say the second most controversial E-Mote of all time.
Warum zum Teufel ist Weird Champ controversial?
Still very far away from the most controversial Twitch E-Mote.
Hahaha, das hat er gut eingeblendet im Hintergrund.
Lul.
Tryhard.
Das hat er gut eingeblendet.
Weil er kennt's kaum.
...we touched on in a later lesson.
And although Weird Champ is deemed a controversial E-Mote, the argument of triggered by pixels
lol w stands pretty strong.
As you can personally see, Weird Champ is deemed a controversial E-Mote.
I personally blocked any E-Mote, so you can't see it anymore.
So if you do indeed get triggered by pixels, then you can't be a safe alternative for you.
The main point of this E-Mote was to be a competitor with Haha, which at the time was
unheard of.
The 12 BTW Haha spam was peaking, and there seemed to be no stop to the barrage of spam
on Twitch.
Weird Champ is better.
But Weird Champ busted onto the scene, and the Haha-Weird Champ war began, with Weird
Champ ultimately being deemed victorious, mostly in part to Twitch literally bitching.
Twitch literally banning people for saying 12 BTW in chat, because you need to be at least 13 to have
an account.
Wobei, ich verwende die beiden E-Motes.
Haha ist für mich so das Cringe-E-Mote, wenn irgendwie was zum Fremdschämen passiert.
Und Weird Champ ist, wenn irgendwie was, keine Ahnung, was merkwürdiges, also nicht, nee,
nicht was merkwürdiges, wenn die Leute merkwürdige Sachen sagen, die aber nicht zum Cringen
reichen.
Dann ist Weird Champ.
Wenn's so richtig cringe ist, dann, ähm, ist Weird Champ.
Äh, ist, ist Haha.
Oder wenn einer was ultra lustig findet, was nicht lustig ist.
So, dann, dann ist, ist das angesagt.
Und wenn jetzt irgendwie einer sagt, keine Ahnung, ähm, ich kacke im Handstand, dann
würd ich sagen Weird Champ anstatt Haha.
...Chambers and a shell of what the E-Mote used to be.
But enough of the history lesson.
Using this E-Mote is pretty straightforward.
See something you don't like or don't agree with?
Weird Champ.
Streamer playing with another streamer that you don't like?
Donation with an awful text-to-speech-Message?
Weird Champ.
For the most part, you're gonna wanna use this E-Mote when anything is, as the E-Mote's
name suggests, weird.
Weird Champ.
And although this E-Mote has a negative connotation attached to it, there are some comedic ways
to use this E-Mote.
Streamer kills an animal on stream?
Instead of using the capital D colon spam, try using Animal Killer, Weird Champ, or Apologize
Now, Weird Champ.
Ich würd sagen, Call Peter, Weird Champ.
...Story Bob with Pog?
You can also swap in Weird Champ as well.
Streamer telling a boring story or playing into a joke until it's no longer funny?
Try using Wrap-It-Up, Weird Champ.
Just please, I beg you, use Weird Champ responsibly, as an unchecked Weird Champ spam can kill
a stream by making everything negative.
And the last E-Mote I'll touch on in this lesson is Pog-O.
It's an E-Mote that has been gaining quite a bit of popularity over the last few months.
It seems as if it's a competitor to Weird Champ, to some extent, but it's still too
early to say if a war will break out between the two E-Motes.
It's still too early to say if a war will break out between the two E-Motes.
And the E-Mote does seem quite niche, only being used in 3,000 channels, compared to Weird Champ's 32,000.
But only time will tell if Pog-O will reign supreme against a powerhouse that is Weird Champ.
And for the rest of the variants of Pog-Champ, there isn't much to touch on, because either they mean the same thing as their counterparts,
or they're just too obscure and niche and used by E-Mote elitists to feel more unique.
E-Mote elitists, alles klar.
Well, it seems that's all the time I have for today.
I hope you learned something from this.
I'll be back soon for another lesson on a new E-Mote.
Yep, adde ich nicht. Yep, ich bin der Einzige, der yappt hier.
And I'll see you guys later.
Die Videos sind übelst gut gemacht.
Warum hat er nur 1.360 Subs?
Gerade das war mega gut, das Video.
Vor allem das Intro.
Haha, ich find das zu geil.
Naja.
So.
Guck mal als nächstes.
How to Pog-Champ.
Nee, das hatten wir grad schon.
Only in Battlefield.
Okay, Battlefield haben wir.
Overclocking.
Valorant-Netcode-Analyse.
Wie Subway sich selbst zerstört.
Programmier-Noob-Fehler.
Garagentor-Dings.
Game Boy.
Zukunft von Diablo.
Was wollen wir denn jetzt gucken?
Was, Subway?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt, das Subway-Video?
Kannst du KQ adden?
KQ?
Das?
Ja, das kann ich adden.
Stimmt, das hatte ich sogar mal vor.
Moment, KQ, ja, ich weiß.
Das wollte ich sogar schon mal adden.
Aber hab's dann nicht gemacht.
Oder hab ich's doch gemacht?
Nee, es ist schon KQ.
Es ist schon KQ.
Moment, gleich ist da.
FFZ ist kaputt gerade.
Warum ist FFZ gerade kaputt?
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt geht's.
So, ich hab's geaddet.
POG.
POG U.
Wenn ihr refresht, müsste POG U funktionieren.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es kurz dauert.
Okay, Subway.
15 Zentimeter oder 30?
Welches Brot?
20.
Wie Elotrix.
Brot.
Hat er nicht immer irgendwas von 20 Zentimeter erzählt?
Welche Beilage?
Welche Soße?
Salz, Pfeffer?
Jeder kennt die Tafel.
Was ist das?
Jeder kennt die Tapfen.
Extra Fleisch.
Extra Käse.
Das ganze sogar von einem Sandwich Artist.
Die belegen nämlich keine Brote.
Nein, die erfüllen Wünsche.
Das wichtigste ist ... für einen Sandwich Artist, dass ...
Sandwich Artist.
Die haben alle immer so überzogene Dinger.
Sie sind freundlich.
Und natürlich auch, dass man schnell arbeitet.
Ja gut, soweit die Werbung.
Subway hat heute mehr als 42.000 Restaurants in über 100 Ländern.
und gehört damit zu den größten Fast-Food-Ketten der Welt.
Sandwich Artist, wo wir jetzt bei Emotes sind,
ist ein typisches Wort, wo man eindeutig mal sagen kann,
das Wort Sandwich Artist ist Weirdchamp.
Subway gibt es auf Mauritius, in Alaska, Sibirien und sogar in Afghanistan.
Zweimal.
In den 90ern ist Subway so richtig explodiert.
In den USA verdreifachte sich die Anzahl der Restaurants.
Auch in europäische und asiatische Märkte wurde aggressiv expandiert.
Knapp 30 Jahre später gehen die Umsätze plötzlich zurück.
In den USA müssen tausende Restaurants schließen.
Der Konzern zerstört sich selbst.
Und man fragt sich, warum?
Das erste Subway wurde 1965 in Connecticut eröffnet.
Das Konzept, gesundes Fast-Food, the American Dream.
Das aggressive Wachstum der 90er war nur durch sogenannte...
Enrico, du musst in die Settings einstellen,
dass deine Twitch-Emotes animiert werden.
Du gehst hier hin.
Da, Settings, FFZ-Control-Center bei der Twitch-TV-Emotes
und schreibst hier GIF-Emotes Enabled.
Enabled Animated GIF-Emotes, nicht Static Animated.
Und dann hast du hier Annele Klepp zum Beispiel.
Es ist Franchising möglich.
Im Prinzip kann jeder ein Subway-Restaurant aufmachen.
Für eine Gebühr gibt Subway seinen Namen und das Konzept her.
Das Ladendesign, die Art der Zubereitung, die Preise,
alles wird von Subway vorgegeben.
12,5% des Monats.
12,5% des monatlichen Umsatzes gehen direkt an Subway.
Dazu kommen dann noch 10.000 Euro Einstiegsgebühr.
Klingt vielleicht erst mal nach nicht so viel,
ist aber ganz schön viel Geld.
Der Umsatz umfasst nämlich alles, was das Restaurant einnimmt.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Profit.
Der Franchise-Nehmer muss sich zusätzlich noch um die Einrichtung,
die Miete, die Gehälter der Angestellten
und alle weiteren Kosten kümmern.
Man muss mit knapp 200.000 Euro rechnen,
bevor man überhaupt das erste Sandwich verkaufen kann.
Und das ist sogar schon ziemlich günstig.
Also, wenn du nicht eh schon ordnest,
wenn du nicht ordentlich Kohle hast,
wirst du das ja nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Muss man mit knapp einer Million Euro rechnen.
Ähnliche Kosten erwarten einen auch bei Burger King.
Bei Starbucks werden Lizenzen
gar nicht an Privatpersonen vergeben.
Das System kann natürlich super gut funktionieren.
Der Franchise-Nehmer profitiert
von der Marke und dem Image
und kümmert sich dafür um das Tagesgeschäft.
Es wird allerdings ziemlich unschön,
wenn der Franchise-Geber eine Fehlentscheidung
nach der anderen trifft
und die Franchise-Nehmer darunter leiden.
Gab's da nicht die Geschichte,
dass Subway-Sandwiches
zumachen mussten,
weil sie
in der Nebenstraße von einem anderen
Subway-Sandwich waren oder sowas?
Ich kann mich ja noch dunkel daran erinnern.
Da gab's doch letztens was, wo sich alle übelst
drüber aufgeregt haben.
Vanilla-Eis 2109
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Big IQ Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Satte 30 cm für 5 Dollar.
Jedes US-Restaurant musste mitziehen.
Das gleiche Angebot gab es auch in Deutschland.
5 Euro.
Das ist schon ein bisschen
Braindead die Werbung.
Weirdchamp. Weirdchamp.
Terrox.
Neun Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Neun Monate ist ja schon fast.
So konnte Subway seinen Umsatz
2009 um 3,8
Milliarden Dollar steigern.
Ein Riesenerfolg. Aber ein finanzielles
Desaster für viele Franchise-Nehmer.
Sie waren zu der Zeit mit der wachsenden
Konkurrenz beschäftigt.
Funnels, Wendy's, Burger King und viele andere
brachten... Moment. Gibt es das in
Deutschland? Nee, oder?
Allesamt neue, gesündere Alternativen
auf den Markt. Subway war plötzlich nicht
mehr die einzige, die endlich gesundes
Fastfood anbietet. Die sowieso schon
Max, gehst du regelmäßig zu Fastfood
lehnen oder eher nicht? Nö. Eigentlich
gar nicht mehr.
...durch den relativ unprofitablen 5 Dollar Footlong
dann nur noch höher. Aber Subway meinte
so. Das reicht uns nicht!
2016 wurde
der 5 Dollar Deal endlich abgeschafft.
Für eine kurze Zeit wollte Subway
das Angebot wieder einführen. Der Plan wurde
aber von einer Revolte der Franchise-Nehmer
verhindert. Ach ja, und wenn man Subway
nicht direkt bezahlt, droht direkt
die Klage. Auch wenn man kurz vorm Bankrott
steht, ist das also keine Option.
Die Verhandlung wird dann laut 700 Seiten
dickem Vertrag vor einem Schiedsgericht in
New York stattfinden. Viel Spaß, wenn du
dafür ohne Geld in der Tasche aus Sibirien
anreisen musst. Bei anderen Franchise-
Unternehmen gibt es solche Extremfälle
wesentlich seltener. McDonalds und Burger
King betreuen ihre Franchise-Nehmer viel
enger. McDonalds sucht beispielsweise die
Standorte der Restaurants aus und richtet sie
ein. Erst dann werden sie an die Betreiber
verpachtet. Sie sind also weniger auf sich
allein gestellt. Subway hat noch ein weiteres
Problem. Die Restaurants müssen keinen
Mindestabschluss haben. Das stimmt, aber sehr viele Subways sind
einfach dicht.
Wie es bei uns um die Ecke früher gegeben hat.
Also,
wie gesagt, dort wo ich immer hin bin
mittags, Subway holen gibt es
ja schon Jahre nicht mehr.
So graben sich viele gegenseitig
die Kunden ab. In Manhattan kann das
Ganze dann schnell so aussehen. Franchise-
Nehmer, die sowieso schon strugglen, werden
dadurch nur noch weiter unter Druck gesetzt.
Aber auch gut laufende, profitable Restaurants
sind nicht sicher. Die einzelnen Restaurants
werden von regionalen Development
Agents koordiniert. Eigentlich müssten
sie dafür sorgen, dass nicht zu viele Subways
nebeneinander eröffnet werden. Die meisten
dieser Development Agents sind aber selber
auch Franchise-Nehmer. Sie konkurrieren
also. Klingt ein bisschen nach
Voreingenommen. Mit den Läden.
Enrico, ich finde Subway auch nicht schlecht. Ich esse
Subway an sich ganz gern.
... die sie eigentlich beaufsichtigen sollen.
Das ist aber natürlich kein Interessenskonflikt.
Auch wenn ich schon lange keins vergessen habe. Subway ist es nur wahnsinnig wichtig,
dass die Development Agents jeden Aspekt
des Unternehmens genau verstehen. Also
auch wie es ist, einen zu besitzen. Dass gut laufenden
Restaurants wegen fadenscheiniger Argumente
immer wieder die Lizenzen entzogen werden,
hängt ganz sicher nicht damit zusammen.
Dass die Agents wenig später im selben Gebiet als
neue Subway-Besitzer auftauchen, ist vermutlich
auch nur Zufall. Unzählige
Subway-Besitzer haben versucht gegen die Machenschaften
der Development Agents zu klagen.
Nur wenige hatten Erfolg, auch weil
Subway ihnen keine Rückendeckung gibt.
haben mehr Subway-Restaurants dichtgemacht
als neue aufgemacht. Das opportunistische
Management und die hohen Gebühren
haben zahlreiche Restaurantbesitzer in den
Ruin getrieben. Und dazu kommen Skandale.
Jared Fogel war 15 Jahre lang
Werbesprecher für Subway. Er hat
behauptet, mit Subway-Produkten über 100
Kilogramm abgenommen zu haben.
Ah, okay. Also
wer sowas glaubt, das rein vom
Subway-Sandwich essen. Man hätte
nicht gedacht, dass man 100 Kilo abnimmt.
Es kommt drauf an,
was man sonst noch so macht.
Ich mein, wenn ich Subway-Sandwich esse
und danach zusätzlich meinen ganzen
anderen Kram, Schwachsinn,
wenn ich nur ein Subway-Sandwich
am Tag esse und dazu
noch Sport mache und sonst wie. Klar,
aber dann muss es auch kein Subway-Sandwich sein.
Das könnte ich auch mit irgendwie x-beliebigen
anderen Sachen machen. Oh,
Pädobär-Alarm.
Da entpuppte sich die Werbeikone als Pädophiler.
Skandale kommen natürlich meistens unerwartet.
Sie sind aber ein zusätzliches Risiko
für Franchise-Nehmer. Wenn Subways Image
geschädigt wird, werden die Umsätze schließlich
noch weiter nach unten getrieben. Einige
Subway-Besitzer sehen sich dadurch gezwungen,
auf minderwertige Produkte zurückzugreifen.
Die Qualität leidet also auch unter
dem enormen Kostendruck. Immer wieder
berichten ausgestiegene Sandwich-Artists
von Hähnchenfleisch, das mehrere Tage
in der Auslage bleibt. Wenn's nicht
stinkt, gern auch mal zählen.
Das würde es ganz ehrlich
erklären, dass ich, jetzt weiß ich nicht,
war ja auch die letzten Male, wo ich einen Subway besucht
hab, seitdem geh ich nicht mehr hin.
Unser Subway hat ja dicht gemacht und
seitdem sind wir ab und zu ja mal,
also in Frankfurt dann, wenn ich
da, wo noch nicht nur Homeoffice war, also
schon ein bisschen her,
zum Subway gefahren sind. Da musstest du
schon eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten mit der U-Bahn
hin und dann futtern. Und da
war ich drei Mal und hatte jedes Mal übelst dünn Schiss
danach. Und seitdem geh ich dann immer hin.
Bis jetzt nur eine amerikanische
Krise. Und bin nie wieder zu Subway gegangen danach.
Außerdem gibt es immer Franchise-Nehmer,
die sich von den Erfolgsversprechen
anlocken lassen. Der tatsächliche
Schaden für Subway könnte also überschaubar
bleiben. Die Kette wird von Tausenden
von Menschen getragen. Sie alle haben viel
Zeit und viel Geld in ihren Traum der
Selbstständigkeit investiert. Sie haben
das radikale Wachstum der 90er überhaupt
erst ermöglicht. Schade, dass Subway
genau diese Menschen heute so
rücksichtslos ausnutzt. Und
sich so letztlich das eigene
Fundament raubt.
Cheers. So sieht's aus.
Hey. Wir haben... Ah, da
der hat was mit... Igitt. Warum hat der
was mit ARD und ZDF zu tun? Ich dachte,
das ist irgendwas unabhängiges.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen ist
mir egal, ob es ARD oder ZDF sind.
Alle
Fernsehgeschichten ist...
Monka ist
höchstens Arte, Alter.
Arte.
Jetzt haben wir
Valorant-Netcode-Analyse.
Oh, der macht
das immer richtig Big Brain. Was haben wir
hier? Oh, so many people.
Ich will sehen, wie der Typ sein
Hoftor automatisiert. Das interessiert
mich irgendwie.
Today on the hookup, I'm gonna walk you through every step of
a simple DIY home automation
project. As we convert a
standard garage door into a smart one
for less than $25, I'm gonna do
my best to explain all the terminology
I use with this pop-up video
style bubble. Making this
the perfect video for any beginner
DIY automator.
In my house tour,
I mentioned that my smart garage door
was my first DIY automation project.
And that for the money, it's probably
one of those smart home automators.
When I was first starting out, every
YouTube video and tutorial that I watched
was full of a bunch of terminology that I didn't really
understand. And as a result, I fumbled around
with a lot of failed protocols before finally
figuring out what I was doing.
This is the video that I wish existed
when I was first starting out.
This video is sponsored by PCBWay,
a well-known circuit board manufacturer.
PCBWay offers full-featured PCB services
Has anyone of you ever
ordered a PCB somewhere,
i.e. upload it with circuit boards
and you were sent the complete board?
Has anyone of you ever tried it,
how well it works?
It's probably going well, right?
Because there's not much to it.
They do thousands of things like that every day.
You have to do three things.
You have to upload this schematics,
upload a circuit board
and upload a part list.
I've even looked at a tutorial about it.
I'm going to explain more about what they are
and why we need them.
You have to connect them
from one pin to another pin
and exactly how it should run on the board.
I've seen a tutorial about it
but I don't know what the steps are.
Here they are.
First is a Shelly 1 Wi-Fi smart relay.
Second is a reed switch and a magnet.
Third a 12V AC adapter
and a thin wire.
I want to definitely make clear that there are purpose-built
smart garage door solutions available
from companies like Moze and Zemismart
for actual installation.
For me, a garage door would be completely pointless.
I don't drive in there with the car
and it's mostly just used as a storage.
You could almost call it a garbage dump.
It's used as a storage.
Okay, when is it going to be built?
I just want to see what it looks like in the end.
I want to see what it looks like in the end.
Show me.
Oh!
Big brain.
Cocona socket.
Freedom, freedom power plug.
Plug in both your garage door opener
and your 12V adapter.
If all goes well, you should now be able
to see the state of your garage door
as indicated by the blue coloration
on the power button in your Shelly app.
Open and close using the power button.
Which again causes that relay to fire
for one second and then turn back off.
Also, ich hätte sowas schon am Start,
würde ich meine Garage verwenden,
um rein und raus zu fahren.
It does this by connecting
to a computer server called the Shelly Cloud.
Normally, if a hub is the ability
to connect to a computer server called the Shelly Cloud.
Oh, voll stylisches Intro.
Oh exquisite video,
Big Brain Topics.
Die Skin-Preise sind eine Frechheit, ja.
Ich glaube, wie war das für 100 Dollar?
Oder waren es 200 Dollar?
Dieses Dragon-Dings, bla, Skin-Pack, wie auch immer das heißt.
Man darf sich über alles beschweren.
Warum soll man sich nicht über Skin-Preise beschweren dürfen?
Natürlich darf man sich über Skin-Preise beschweren.
120 Euro, ja, ist ja schon echt teuer.
Klar, letztendlich musst du es nicht kaufen.
Aber man kann sich trotzdem darüber beschweren, dass es zu teuer ist.
Weil, ne, versetz dich mal in die Situation rein.
Irgendjemand würde gerne den Skin kaufen, das ist ihm zu teuer.
Also darf man sich auch darüber beschweren.
Warum nicht?
Brauchen tust du nicht.
Aber beschweren kannst du dich trotzdem drüber.
Zumal in der heutigen Zeit kannst du dich über alles beschweren.
Warum sollst du dich nicht auch über Skin-Preise beschweren dürfen?
Das ist ein Rundtrip-Zeit, der fast 10 Millisekunden niedriger ist, als das, was das Spiel mir gezeigt hat.
Der Grund dafür ist, dass...
In Pass of Exile sind die Sachen auch teilweise ultra teuer.
Wenn du dir überlegst, dass da irgendwie ein Schild-Skin teilweise 150 Points kostet und 150 Points sind was, 20 Euro oder so?
Das ist teilweise auch komplett übertrieben.
Diese IP hier ist nicht zu teuer.
Trotzdem habe ich mir welche gekauft.
Es ist der Eingangspunkt in Amazon's Global Accelerator-Netzwerk.
Wie ich in der Netcode 101 Video erklärt habe, ist dein Ping, oder der Rundtrip-Zeit zwischen deinem Klient...
Das ist ein gutes Thema.
Er schreibt, die Skins sind trotzdem billiger, als wenn man die mit Loot-Boxen freischalten würde.
Hier sieht man wenigstens, wie behindert teuer das ist.
Das ist eindeutig ein Fall von den Preis in den Köpfen der Leute, also die Sachen in den Köpfen der Leute künstlich wertvoller machen, als sie eigentlich sind.
Das ist was, was gerne Mobile-Games machen.
Also du kriegst dann...
In Mobile-Games haben sie zum Beispiel Sachen drin, wie...
Du kannst dir einen Juwel für 1 Euro kaufen, oder 5 Juwele für 5 Euro.
Und dann gibt es einen Juwel-Pack, einen Monat gratis testen, mit 5 Juwelen umsonst drin.
Und dann denkst du dir alle, boah klar, natürlich, ich mach das Monat gratis.
Und dann...
Das gibt künstlich einer Sache einen Wert, den es nicht hat.
Das ist so eine typische Mobile-Taktik.
Mobile-Game-Taktik.
... Server.
It's not only a fact...
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Also mal angenommen, ich mache eine Preisliste als Mobile- oder als Game-Anbieter und schreibe hin, 1 Microtransaction-Point kostet 1 Euro.
5 Microtransaction-Points kosten, keine Ahnung, 4 Euro oder so.
So, und dann habe ich dem irgendwie einen Preis zugeordnet.
Also, ne?
5 Points 4 Euro, 1 Point 1 Euro.
Was im Kopf hängen bleibt, ist so ungefähr 1 Euro pro Point.
So, und jetzt verkaufe ich ein Monats-Abo, was allerdings den ersten Monat kostenlos ist.
Wo man sogar 5 Points umsonst kriegt.
Oder 5 Points nur für 1 Euro.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Und schon sagen die Leute, wow, cool, hier kriege ich ja quasi was, was sonst 4 Euro kostet, kriege ich für 1 Euro.
Das lohnt sich ja viel mehr.
Dabei ist es ein komplett fiktiver Preis, ohne irgendwie eine Begründung, also einen Anhaltspunkt, warum das jetzt auf einmal so viel wert sein soll.
Das ist so eine Taktik, die machen die bei Mobile-Games.
Ultra gerne.
Wahrscheinlich auch bei allen möglichen anderen Webshops.
The Routing.
Ja, der hat bestimmt ein Cisco-Zertifikat.
Er sagt Routing.
Your data might take a direct route, which keeps the network delay and the risk of packet loss low.
But you can also end up in a situation where your data takes quite a detour, which can have a very negative impact on your connection to the server.
So, Amazons Global Accelerator Service aims to decrease the latency and increase the stability of a connection by having the traffic of an application enter their own network through one of the nearest...
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht doof.
It is similar to how services like Haste or WTFast try to improve your connection by routing your data through their own network.
One of the reasons why developers choose to use a service like this...
Und du musst den Kram natürlich auch nicht selbst betreiben.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht, dass es so was mittlerweile gibt.
Für halbwegs erschwinglich.
...to mitigate the problem of players with a low and stable ping to the server receiving damage behind cover when they get shot by a player who has a bad connection to the server.
A service like the AWS Global Accelerator helps to reduce the round-trip time of your player base.
But it does not help when players suffer from buffer bloat or congestion inside their whole network...
Das habe ich nicht gesehen.
...which can lead to massive ping spikes of several hundred milliseconds.
Massive!
...which also doesn't help much when a player connects to a server outside his own region.
Ja.
For these instances you need other lag mitigation strategies that prevent players who have a connection issue from degrading the online experience of players who have a good and stable connection to the server.
So, even though I had to slightly lead my shot which suggests that Valorant does use a threshold for how much lag it compensates,
the player with the low ping still received the shot quite far behind cover.
On a positive note, there are no hits from the grave, which means that the server will cancel a hit from a player if that player was killed before the shot was directed at them.
Das ist nicht wie in Battlefield, wo die Leute mit ewig Ping dich quasi um fünf Ecken killen, wenn sie selbst schon in die Luft geflogen sind.
In Battlefield war es teilweise gang und gäbe, dass du dich gegenseitig gekillt hast.
As the in-game overlay shows, the game servers run at a tick rate of 128 Hz.
Which means that they do 128 simulation steps per second.
As I explained in the Netcode 1 video, a high tick rate not only reduces delays, it also makes the game more resilient.
Ich mein, wie war das? Zehner-Tick-Server in Warzone?
Less of an issue then, and clients have to do less guesswork between packets than in other games which run at a lower tick rate.
If you suspect the game server to have a performance issue, then you should enable this overlay and keep an eye on the simulation rate.
If it stays at 128, then all should be fine.
If you see it drop constantly or not even reach 128, which I've not seen during my testing,
then this suggests that the server has a performance issue which can have a negative impact on your online experience.
Außer man spielt über Stadia, dann hat man negative latency.
Warzone für eine Tickrate? Ich glaube Warzone hatte eine Zehner-Tickrate.
Zwanziger! Zwanziger!
Oder Zwölfer?
Auf jeden Fall wenig!
Ist vielen sehr echt nicht normal, denn das hängt komplett von der Implementierung und vom Game ab, wie du's machst.
But these are easy to measure with Wireshark.
So when you play Valorant with more than 144 FPS on a 128-Tick-Server,
dann, as long as you are alive, your client sends 73 packets per second to the server.
When you die, then the send rate of your client drops to about 5 updates per second.
But that's not an issue, because you are dead then.
The send rate of the server, on the other hand, is around 115 packets per second.
And it doesn't drop when you die.
However, I decided to calculate the average only for the time I was alive,
so that these average values are for the same portion of the recorded data.
What I find interesting is that the send rate of the client seems to be at a somewhat stable 73 packets per second.
Usually you see game clients use a send rate that at least matches the tickrate of the server.
So it might be possible to further decrease the network delay in Valorant
by increasing the send rate of the client to 128 packets per second.
When it comes to the variable send rate of the server,
then the developers most likely have the server only send necessary updates to the clients.
Aber, sagen wir mal so, ich kann ja da eh nicht...
Ich kann ja da als Spieler nichts verändern.
... as that reduces the stress on the player's internet connection,
where packets per second can turn into a limiting factor before bandwidth.
Besides the performance overlays, Valorant has another interesting setting in its options menu,
called network buffering, which you can set to minimum, moderate or maximum.
When you hear network buffering, then you might think of how the interpolation ratio in Counter-Strike works.
So I thought that this setting would change how many incoming packets
get buffered, which increases the network delay,
but can help with stuttering player animations, especially when you suffer from packet loss.
However, it seems like the network buffering setting in Valorant doesn't work that way.
Take a look at what happens when the player in front of me changes his network buffering setting.
When he changes this setting, it causes that his player model stutters on my client.
This setting does not affect the animation smoothness of how he sees other players,
but how smooth his player model moves for everyone else.
Okay, das heißt die meisten Leute stellen das jetzt alle auf Maximum, oder wie?
... this feature actually does.
When you choose the moderate or maximum network buffering setting,
then these decrease how frequently your client sends data to the server.
Fewer updates sent means that your player model stutters for other players,
and that you have more network delay.
The only reason why you would want to choose any other value than minimum here,
is when the send rate of the game causes issues for your internet connection.
Ja, mal ganz einfach, es lohnt sich trotzdem nicht,
wenn dann deine Schüsse später recken und sowas, ne, das ist natürlich auch bescheuert.
... I do not like that players are even given that option.
The game should on its own be able to determine when the internet connection of a player
cannot handle the default update rates, and then adjust them automatically.
We can look at Battlefield as a great example here,
which uses such a system since Battlefield 4, and it works really well.
That said, I do not like that you have to do this.
I do not like that the animation of a player starts to stutter for everyone else
when the send rate of this player is reduced.
Though preventing that would probably increase the delay for everyone,
as the game then might have to buffer more packets and interpolate between them.
Now, let's take a look at the delays the two players experience
when they play on the same server and at the same network latency of 24ms.
Long story short, the delays for damage, gunfire and player movement were not only good,
they are also nearly identical, which is quite rare.
There is also only a very small difference between the shortest, average and longest delays,
which is one of the positive effects a high tick rate of 128Hz has on the delays.
That said, compared to other games, there is still room for improvement here.
So, I am curious how the network delays in Valorant will hopefully improve,
as the developers continue to update the game.
Warum ist Apex Legends so schlecht?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass Apex, also gerade weil es so ein Titanfall-Background ist,
ziemlich, ziemlich gut funzt.
Warzone ist leider nicht drin.
Overwatch ist allgemein ziemlich gut, was Netzwerksachen angeht.
Also über eine Sache kann man sich bei Overwatch nicht beschweren.
Netzwerktechnisch ist das Spiel wunderbar.
Now, even though the next two features are only indirectly related to the netcode
and the online performance of the game,
I still want to highlight the fact,
that the developers decided to have the game determine the highest supported refresh rate of your monitor
and then only allow the player to choose that refresh rate.
As Valorant runs at a tick rate of 128Hz,
Ist das so?
you do want to play the game at a refresh rate of at least 120Hz
and more than 120FPS to get the most out of that high tick rate.
By only allowing players to select the highest supported refresh rate,
they eliminate a potential configuration error,
as players cannot select the two lowest supported refresh rates,
which would have a negative impact on their online experience.
Another great feature, which I would like to get in every game,
is a built-in frame rate limiter,
which allows you to dial in a specific frame rate value.
That is especially useful when you own a G-Sync or FreeSync display,
as well as when you want to cap the frame rate at a value that your PC can always maintain
and so achieve perfectly stable frame times.
So while there is always room for improvement,
I'm quite happy with how Valorant performed in my tests,
as well as the good amount of networking-related features Riot Games included in the game.
I hope that they will continue to update and enhance what they have built so far,
and I will do my best to test the game again
and let you know how these changes affect the game.
And that's all for today.
I want to thank my Patrons for their awesome support,
and if you would like to join them,
then you can find a link to my Patreon page in the description.
If you enjoyed this video, then please give it a like, subscribe for more,
ring the bell to get notified when I upload a new video,
and I will see you in the next video.
Have a nice day and take care.
My name is Chris and this was Battle Nonsense.
Probably has done the War Song,
but I don't wanna watch a 30-minute War Song Netcode analysis video.
Battlefield, ok, excellent.
Bad Company 2-Music, yeah.
Dude, what's going on with the enemies?
Both fuck?
The snipers!
Stayed stuck.
Ich mach den absichtlich nicht lauter, weil der sagt eh immer das gleiche und ich schwätz immer drüber.
Boah, Console, Console-Graphics.
Ist das, was ist das? PS3?
Aber eigentlich die Auflösung zu hoch für PS3. Das ist glaube ich, das ist glaube ich doch PC, nur mit schlechter Capture.
Ja, so Dinger hast du viele, sowas hattest du aber an vielen Stellen im Battlefield, dass du Wände hattest, wo du nicht durchschießen konntest.
Na, trifft er ihn jetzt noch?
Hä?
Weird Champ, das ist immer gescheit.
Oh, Sturm.
Oh, ähm.
What?
What the hell?
Ja, aber das sind so Sachen, die sind geil, dass sie in Battlefield unscripted passieren.
Weil er hat halt den Chat auf den Kopf gekriegt.
Oh!
Wow!
Double, Double Hit mit einer, das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
What the?
Battlefield Physics.
What?
WTF?
Game!
She baited!
Wait, wait.
Das geht?
Das geht!
Geil, das muss ich gleich nachher ausprobieren.
As I've said before a million times, Battlefield 4 and before that Battlefield 3 were both known for the epic moments and incredible clips that you could record pretty much every single time you played.
Both were amazing arenas for only a matter of moments, with both focusing on that sandbag hellhound, you could approach the game in any way you wanted, with a huge amount of variety, whether you enjoyed vehicle clips, infantry plays, or just pure luck, these clips have got you covered.
Fat Wombat.
Hell yeah!
Double kill!
That's eight!
Yeah!
What?
Wie hat der denn...
Haha!
Der hat den Roadkilled, lol!
Der springt da jetzt auf den Heli, oder?
Nice.
Und wieder ins Auto rein, das ist progress.
Schauen wir mal wie die Dudes, wie oft werden die Dudes auf diesem, auf dem Strommast noch zeigen.
Go down, go down, yeah, yeah!
Hier gesynkte Wellen.
Hold.
Fuck.
Pass auf, das trifft jetzt drei Minuten sp...
What?
Oh, okay, das war einfach mal Lucky irgendwo an den Arsch der Welt geschossen, grob vorgehalten und da ist reingefogen.
Oh, nice!
Das ist doch nice.
Battlefield ist auch das einzige Game, wo man einen Eurofighter auf ner, auf ner, äh, dreckigen Wiese mit Bäumen startet.
Moment, was gibt das, wenn's fertig ist?
Hahaha!
Geil!
Und RIP.
Oh, und wieder eine... das ist ein nicer Kill.
Ich seh überhaupt nicht, wo da was ist.
Äh, what?
Ah!
E2?
Oh, Germans am Start.
Das ist mal ein guter Clip.
Also von der Auflösung her, von der Quali her.
Ist das Golf of Oman Battlefield 4?
Nee.
Ist das Carc... Carc Island?
Nee, was ist das?
Was, was das, war das...
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Carc Island, da vorne kann's aber nicht sein.
Ist es doch Golf, Golf of Oman Battlefield 4?
Wanderwüste, okay, siehste mal.
Ah.
Boah, der war cool.
Boah, ist der besoffen?
Boah, mein Gott.
I'm in.
Da wird's dir ja schlecht bei.
The next Bug is from Fancy Andy.
I will slow this one down.
I'm not sure what the hell is happening here,
but it seems like...
Facerolling!
Der facerollt den Gegner.
Wortwörtlich.
The Bug is from Fancy Andy.
Der facerollt.
Hallo?
Das ist ja geil. Er facerollt wirklich.
Das sieht geil aus.
Only in Battlefield.
Er fliegt in seinen Attack-Helikopter,
springt aus der Seite, um es zu reparieren
und dann wird er unter der Karte verletzt.
Und französisch versucht er wieder rein zu kommen.
Er kann es nicht. Und er wird in Aktion getötet.
Danke fürs Zuschauen dieses Episodes von Only in Battlefield.
Ich hoffe wirklich, dass ihr es genossen habt.
Ich habe versucht, den Kommentar zu einem Minimum zu geben.
Die anderen Videos sind einfach besser.
Mit den Clips und...
Wir haben ja gestern 24 Uhr aufgehört.
Ende Akt 5.
Mitte Akt 5? Anfang Akt 5?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo genau.
Na, Battlefield habe ich heute keinen Bock drauf.
Es wird so anstrengend.
Ist das neu? Gibt es noch eine aktive Community?
Äh, ja.
Also sowohl Battlefield 3 als auch Battlefield 4
kannst du auf dem PC noch ohne Probleme spielen.
Battlefield 3 hat nicht mal so viele aktive Server,
aber du findest abends immer 2-3 Server Rush,
wo du gut drauf spielen kannst.
Oder auch eher so 3-4 Server.
Battlefield 4 findest du noch deutlich mehr.
Und ansonsten...
kannst du spielen, ja.
Also Battlefield 3 DLCs
ist schwierig.
Battlefield 3 DLCs ist schwer,
weil DLC-Server gibt es kaum noch.
Aber ich versuche alles, was ich kann.
Und ich versuche,
so viele Spieler wie möglich mitzunehmen.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Lasst ein Like da, wenn ihr es genossen habt.
Und lasst auch ein Dislike da, wenn ihr es nicht genossen habt.
Und ich werde euch...
in die Kommentare schicken.
Oh, jetzt kommt Bogenstelz nochmal.
Geil!
Das ist ja geil.
Mit dem Mörser in den Sack geschossen.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist ja geil.
Das wusste ich gar nicht,
dass das geht.
Aber das Coole ist bei Battlefield,
es gibt viele Dinge, wo man denkt,
ich wundere mich, dass es auf einmal geht.
Und das Spiel sieht das irgendwie vor.
Aber halt ungescriptet.
Und es passiert einfach.
Das ist halt schon nice.
Was, er hat auch noch einen Headshot-Bonus gekriegt?
Poggers.
Des LFG, No FR.
Da kannst du Franzosen in MMOs übelst triggern.
Des LFG ist französisch Looking for Croup.
Und da musst du No FR dahinter schreiben.
Da wirst du geflamed.
Also wenn du auf französisch Looking for Croup schreibst
und dann hinterher No FR,
dann ist Rage Mode angesagt.
Da verstehen sie keinen Spaß.
Das ist vorbei.
Essential Tools.
Okay, was gucken wir jetzt?
Was gucken wir jetzt?
Wir haben noch ein paar Videos.
Wie lange sind wir eigentlich schon on?
Was gucken wir jetzt?
Essential Tools for Electronic Projects.
Zukunft von Diablo.
Irgendein Raspberry Pi selbst gebauter Game Boy.
Das ist langweilig.
Newbie Programming Mistakes.
Und, der Auer,
Overclocking Wunder durch deaktivierte Grafikeinheit.
Und, der Auer, Overclocking Wunder durch deaktivierte Grafikeinheit.
Newbie Programming Mistakes.
Okay, dann gucken wir erst das und dannốcnen wir den Auer.
Danach kommen wir in Diablo. Wir gucken eh alle.
Den guck ich öfters ...
...nach nach nach komm wir in Diablos.
Der macht gutte Videos.
Der hat richtig krasse Tribade Videos.
Der macht manchmal Videos.
verkauft
und du denkst also das ist gebatet das muss gebatet sein
und dann ist es meistens auch gebatet
so also gucken wir mal
Programming Mistakes
ja und er hat und er hatet Angular zu recht
Things that you can remedy to fix what you're doing
so tip number one or mistake number one is putting everything into a single file
and it becomes... Hätte er nicht vielleicht mal die Hintergrundmusik ausmachen können?
...to a single file and it becomes giant
Moin Twinko
ja das ist tatsächlich
das sind Sachen die machen aber auch Leute die schon eine Weile programmieren
die machen den Fehler zu viel in eine Datei zu packen
oder was heißt zu viel in eine Datei
logische Einheiten zu groß zu machen
in C Sharp mag das dann irgendeine Klasse sein
die irgendwie 2000 Zeilen lang ist oder sowas
das ist auch für einen Arsch
Spaghetti Coat
weiß nicht wie man es am besten nennt so
Feature Creep irgendwie
Ich kann jetzt HTML und CSS reicht das für Basic Landing Page?
Ja
Wenn du einfach nur eine Basic Landing Page machen willst ohne Funktion reicht das
Macht er das Video in der Kantine?
Ja es sieht aus es sieht aus als nimmt er das in der Kantine auf
...and I put everything into a single widget
It's an easy mistake to do cause it's kind of nice at the start of something
to put everything in just a single widget
a single file or a single function
but it does not scale well at all
and it doesn't work as your project grows
so if you see that all over the place giant files
it's a good idea to start splitting things up into smaller sections
and of course it's not the error
Sachen die zusammen gehören einfach zu splitten nur um sie zu splitten
guckt euch dieses Header Gewurschtel an in C++
da kommst du dir vor wie 1985
There are some exceptions where you may want to have a larger function somewhere
but in general you don't want to have just large files everywhere
Alright so number two problem is manually formatting code
So I see people just going around and tabbing
Ja unser Special Azubi der hat auch sein Code manuell formatiert
Ihr kennt den den Zellattenzaun Azubi
Der hat auch seine Sachen seine Einrückung immer von Hand gemacht
...left and right trying to get things lined up
and it's a total waste of time
und war übelst angepisst dass es so eklig zu bedienen ist alles
...to your IDE and just avoid the whole time consuming process
of making sure you have four spaces
Was ein Kultmoment hab ich den Chat auf?
Ja guck mal was?
Ein Kollege hat mir gesagt keiner schreibt heute mehr HTML stimmt das?
Nö
Alle
Heute wird mehr HTML produziert als jemals zuvor
Das ist Schwachsinn
Das ist Blödsinn
Also ich glaube aktuell wird
aufgrund also aufgrund dessen
dass viele Apps
CSS HTML JavaScript sind
die ganze Geschichte immer mehr ins Web geht
Desktop Anwendungen heute Elektron HTML CSS sind
JavaScript sind
Heute gibt es mehr HTML als jemals zuvor
Was?
Er meint alles wird über JavaScript
Ne das stimmt nicht
Am Ende
Am Ende kommt HTML raus
Beziehungsweise
Am Ende kommt eine DOM raus
Ja
Und ja sowas wie
Wenn du sowas wie React verwendest
Die haben ja also die bauen ja
Aus JavaScript HTML im Endeffekt zusammen
Oder aus JavaScript DOM zusammen aber
Ansonsten
Es ist ja im Prinzip noch HTML
Ja
Und wenn es nicht gerade React ist
Also
Die meisten Webseiten bestehen ganz normal aus HTML
Kann man überhaupt ein Webprojekt ohne HTML machen?
Naja man kann theoretisch ein Webprojekt ohne HTML machen
Allerdings nicht ohne DOM
Das muss man ja unterscheiden
Die DOM ist quasi
Die interne Repräsentation
Der Webseite im Browser
Also sprich wie das
Zusammenhängt
Also sprich Parent Elemente
Child Elemente
Die DOM kannst du auch erstellen über JavaScript
Warum sollte ich das machen?
Dafür gibt es HTML
Also es gibt Sachen wie beispielsweise React
Die machen sehr viel JavaScript Magic
Aber meine persönliche Lieblingsgeschichte
Ist ja immer noch Vue.js
Und das ist auch
Zwar viel JavaScript dabei
Weil es ist ja eine JavaScript Library
Aber du hast nach wie vor HTML
Für die Webseite
CSS für Styling
Und JavaScript für die Logik
Vue 3 kommt bald, ja das erzählen sie seit einem Jahr
Schon
Ne also das stimmt nicht
Ähm
Das stimmt nicht
Also heute wird mehr
Heute wird mehr HTML produziert
Als jemals zuvor
Ich will auch Vue.js lernen
Was bringt mir das
Wenn ich nur Basic Pages machen will
Du kannst Vue.js für Basic Pages
Ähnlich verwenden wie jQuery
Du musst da keine großartigen Build Tools installieren
Du machst Script
Include Vue.js und kannst loslegen
Es ist halt einfacher
Die Webseiten interaktiv zu machen
Mit Vue.js als komplett JavaScript von Hand
Ich weiß ja nicht
Was du unter Basic Pages verstehst
Ich weiß ja nicht was für dich eine Basic Page ist
Ja und
Vue.js Code ist top für Frontend
Das stimmt
So gucken wir mal weiter
Warum nimmt der das Video in der Kantine auf
Das verstört mich
Ich glaube das ist zu viel Output
Das ist meistens wenn man Debuggt
Und ich sehe jemanden der versucht einen Bug in seinem Code zu finden
Und die machen nur 100 Print Statements
Und dann wenn sie ihre Code
Wer würde denn sowas machen
Wer würde denn 100 Print Statements hintereinander
Machen
Wer macht denn sowas
Wer könnte denn auf die Idee kommen sowas zu machen
Also ich ja nicht
Sie bekommen nur dieses massive Log Statement
Das sie jetzt durch die Logs drücken
Um zu finden was passiert ist
Stattdessen
Möchtest du
Precise Print Statements
In spezifischen Orten
Die sinnvoll sind
Wenn der Wert dieser Variablen
Zutrifft
Und so weiter
Ja das stimmt
Einfach sinnlos Prints reinhauen braucht man nicht
Also man braucht nicht in einer Funktion
50 Prints
An dieser Stelle wurde Variable gesetzt
Jetzt ist der Inhalt das
Man muss es an die passenden Stellen machen
Ich persönlich bin ja ein großer Fan von Print Debugging
Ich weiß man kann Breakpoints machen
Man kann Debugger Attach und alles mögliche
Aber ich mach gerne Print Debugging
Prints sind teuer
Ja wenn man die
Also mal angenommen ich hätte jetzt
Irgendwo ne
Keine Ahnung irgendwie FFM Pack
Was Videostreams einliest in der Schleife
Da würde ich kein Print machen
Das frisst natürlich schon was
Aber wenn du 5 Prints pro Request machst
Ist das jetzt ja nur wirklich nicht das Ding
Muss ich halt überlegen wo man es macht
Deswegen haben die meisten ja auch noch irgendeinen Debug Flag
Wo du sagen kannst hier Debug an Debug aus
Aber ich mag Print Debugging
Ich bin Fan von Print Debugging
Also der Sir of Jelly möchte einfach
Ne Seite für den Friseur machen
Hast schon mal mit Django
Django CMS kenn ich nicht
Ich kenn Django das ist so ein Python
Backend Web Framework
Wenn du einfach nur
Ne Seite machen willst
Ohne großartige
Funktionen wirst du trotzdem
Nicht um ein bisschen JavaScript heute rumkommen
Ein bisschen JavaScript
Brauchst du schon allein für
Keine Ahnung
Irgendwie ne ordentliche Slideshow von
Angenommen ne Friseur Seite
Hat Bilder mit Leuten
Mit verschiedenen Frisuren
Wenn du da einen schönen Slider machen willst
Zwischen den Bilder dann brauchst du JavaScript
Und Typescript ist auch nochmal ein Ding
So cool Typescript ist
Ich glaube wenn man gerade anfängt zu lernen
Und schon komplett beschäftigt ist mit HTML
CSS und dann ein bisschen JavaScript
Dann noch zusätzlich Typescript reinhauen
Ist ein bisschen
Overload an neuen Sachen
So sinnvoll Typescript auch ist
Später kann man das natürlich machen
Aber gleich am Anfang mit Typescript
Glaub ich ist zu Overkill
Da kriegst du zu viel, musst du zu viel auf einmal machen
Wenn du anfängst und dann lernst du HTML
CSS, JavaScript Basics
Dann lernst du gleich noch irgendwie Vue.js dabei
Typescript
Dann musst du noch irgendwelche Packer sonst was lernen
Wenn er eh Vue.js macht
Naja wieso er kann doch
Wenn er wirklich nur ganz kleine Seiten machen will
Dann kann er einfach
Vue.js Dropin
Script Tag Include machen
Und seine
Minimal Logik
Die er da hat
Da inline alles in der Seite schreiben
Ja wenns größer wird
Wenns größer wird geb ich dir natürlich recht
Dann
Kann man sich auch mal was überlegen
Mit Vue.cli erstellen
Mit Webpack das ganze bilden lassen
Ähm
Und ich muss sagen ich
Hab Vue.js
Noch nie mit Typescript verwendet
Ich habs mir vorgenommen fürs Dreier
Weil das Dreier jetzt zum ersten mal wohl richtig guten
Out of Box Typescript Support hat
Ich hab bisher alles mit
Vue.js
Vanilla JavaScript also kein Typescript gemacht
Geht auch
Mein schöner mags mit Typescript
Typescript sein das glaub ich dir
Was ist dein Lieblings CSS Framework
Ich liebe Tailwind CSS
Mit Tailwind hab ich mir letztens
Tutorial angeguckt
Da hab ich nicht viel mit gemacht
Was ich mag ist weil ich bin ja eigentlich
Kein großartiger Web Pro
Ja
Also ich bau immer Web Frontends für Sachen
Die ich halt wo man halt ein Frontend für braucht
Ähm
Ich verwende meistens das da
Hast du schon mal ein Storybook erstellt
Zum Beispiel mit React
Nein React hab ich noch gar nichts gemacht
Ich mag das hier
Wenn man wohlgemerkt wenn man
Google Material Design mag
Dann ist das ganz nice
Wenn man kein
Material Design mag dann sollte man davon
Abstand nehmen
Weil das ist Material Design Deluxe
Was richtig eklig ist übrigens by the way
Weiß nicht was sich Google dabei
Gedacht hat
Der Time Picker
Das ist
Richtig abartig
Wer bei Google hat sich gedacht
So lässt sich intuitiv
Eine Uhrzeit auswählen
What the fuck
Es sieht
Es sieht hässlich wie die Nacht aus
Und es ist umständlich als Fakt zu bedienen
Weirdjamp
Massive wow
So viel Weirdjamp wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht einblenden gerade
Ich hätte gerne so ein Drehrad
Das ist ne Geschmäcker
Also ich mag den Appleway lieber
Ich mag den Appleway mit diesen
Laufrädern
Lieber
Na gut gucken wir mal weiter
Briefie
Das habe ich mir mal angeguckt
Das ist doch diese Bulma
CS und Vue.js in einem
Oder
Oder bring ich es jetzt durcheinander
Das hatte ich mir auch mal kurz angeguckt
Ja genau doch dann
Habe ich mir das mal kurz angeguckt
Ahja
So gucken wir mal weiter
Das sind
Also die zwei Sachen die wir uns angeguckt haben
Das
Sind fertige
User
Also fertige Komponenten
Die du in deiner Webseite verwenden kannst
Also mit
Ja tatsächlich
Deswegen hat er es so benannt
Er wollte es ursprünglich Trunks nennen
Tatsächlich von Dragon Ball
Das sind fertige Komponenten
Die du quasi einfach nur
In dein Dokument
Einfügst und dann gehen sie
So weit von der Theorie her
Also du hast dein HTML
Und beziehungsweise nein
Du hast dein Template für Vue.js
Und dann fügst du dann eine Vuetify Data Table ein
Und dann kriegst du eine schöne Tabelle
Wo du filtern kannst
Wobei ich die Vuetify Data Table sehr nervig finde
So gucken wir mal
Ich bin noch stehen geblieben
Ein
Debug Print Beste
Exzellent
Aber ich gebe ihm recht
Man sollte nicht sinnlose Prints
In seinem Code verteilen
Sondern an der Stelle wo es einem hilft
Den Fluss nachvollziehen zu können
Ja das stimmt
Das stimmt
Aber man klickt schnell mal weg
Das ist ein Fehler
Oder was du tun musst ist in der Fehler Message zu klicken
Aber du lest die Fehler Message überhaupt nicht
Ich sehe das immer
Ich mache das auch manchmal
Wenn ich einen Fehler bekomme
Und bevor ich den Fehler Message lese
Gehe ich entweder zurück in meinen Code
Oder kopiere und paste die Fehler in Google
Anstatt einfach den Fehler zu lesen
Und zu sagen oh ja ich weiß wie man das lösen kann
Ich kann einfach nur das was die Fehler Message sagt machen
Im Gegensatz zu Java
Ja
Wo in Java erstmal der
20 Seiten Stack Trace am Start ist
Und du irgendwo gucken musst
Ah ok Moment hier Host is unreachable
Sind die meisten
Nicht alle die meisten .NET Fehlermeldungen
Ziemlich gut
Achja und C++ Compiler Fehlermeldungen
Da hast du recht
JW9S
C++ Compiler Fehlermeldungen
Also gerade C++ Compiler Fehlermeldungen
Sind der größte Scheiß den es gibt
Das muss man so klar sagen
Du vergisst an der falschen Stelle
Von einem Template
Oder du machst
Einen Komma an der falschen Stelle
C++ spammt dich voll
Mit Dingern
In Files in denen du gar nicht was bearbeitet hast
Wir
Wir ohne Ende
Ich könnte mich
Darüber auslassen
Warum C++ so suckt
Ich glaube nicht dran
Jeden Standard wird es nur noch verwirrender
Die sollen
C++++ machen
Irgendwie neue Version
Die sollen mal im Jahr 2020 ankommen
Die sollen ordentliches
Metadata Modulsystem mal endlich einbauen
Diese ganze Header File Crap
Da wir sind im Jahr 2020
Das ist echt schlecht
Wenn du das immer noch so machst
Weil ich merke
Du hast einfach nur etwas
Wo du immer noch kopierst
Ich weiß gar nicht wo ist er denn jetzt stehen geblieben
Es hat normalerweise etwas was du tun solltest
Okay Nummer 5
Kopier und Paste Code
Du hast keine Ahnung wie es funktioniert
Wissen sie ich mache das immer von Stack Overflow
Stack Overflow Driven Programming
Copy Paste
Und einfach unterschiedlich anordnen
Bis es wieder funktioniert
Das ist etwas was wirklich schlecht wird
Wenn du das immer noch so machst
Weil ich merke
Du hast einfach nur etwas
Wo du immer noch kopierst
Es gibt Teile davon
Die du nicht verstehen kannst
Wenn du diese Code in anderen Orten benutzt
Und jetzt hast du nur unverwendetes Code
Das wirklich nicht funktioniert
Und es klappt alles
Also verstehe den Code
Bevor du kopierst und paste
Und wenn du...
Ja er hat an der Stelle schon recht
Anzugucken ist
Low Brain
Stack Overflow Code copy pasten und anpassen
Das es bei einem gut funktioniert
Ist allerdings dafür pfeifert
Ja das stimmt
Man muss nicht alles in eine Liste packen
Man muss nicht umgedreht alles in einen Dictionary packen
Je nachdem das stimmt
Da gibt es schon ein paar Sachen wo man drauf achten sollte
...
durch die, immer
die Hälfte durch deine
Datastructure durch. Das Ding ist sortiert
und du machst Hälfte, Hälfte, Hälfte,
Hälfte, bis du es gefunden hast. Also du springst
da ziemlich rum. So,
es kann teilweise
viel schneller
sein, obwohl es theoretisch langsamer ist,
wenn du eine Liste hast
und du machst einfach Liste
von Null bis Ende
und in jedem Fall checkst du,
ob es das Element ist, was du suchst.
Das ist logisch
gesehen langsamer, aber
dadurch, dass du beispielsweise vielleicht die Liste
in deinen CPU
Cache reinpackst,
ist es schneller, obwohl es
in der Theorie langsamer sein müsste.
Also man muss da auch manchmal
ein bisschen gucken, dass Theorie und
Praxis doch
sich unterscheiden können.
Also theoretisch bist du mit einer
sortierten Liste und Binary
Search immer schneller,
aber, also
wenn du mal, wenn die Liste schon
sortiert ist, wenn du natürlich die immer neu sortieren musst,
dann sag mal Fraggle, ja,
aber in der Praxis
kann es durchaus besser sein, einfach
Brute Force,
Iteration durch und gucken, ob es passt.
Instead of doing that, put everything into a
Map and then look it up in 0 of 1 time.
Deswegen finde ich es an vielen Stellen gar nicht schlecht,
wenn man was bastelt,
man macht einfach mal einen Timer drumherum und guckt,
lässt das Ding einfach
50.000 mal laufen und
guckt, ob es wirklich einen großen Unterschied macht
oder ab wann es anfängt, einen Unterschied
zu machen, weil es ist schön und gut,
wenn ich sage, ja, ich sortiere
das jetzt, dann mache ich Binary Search und sonst was.
Wenn es eine Liste ist mit 500 Elementen,
das juckt 500,
das ist nix. Reden wir von
500 Millionen, okay, dann fängt es vielleicht,
an Sinn zu machen
langsam, aber meistens
bei vielen Sachen muss man sich gar nicht so viel
Gedanken machen und oftmals ist das, was man
so direkt,
das, was am einfachsten zu lesen ist,
sogar dem vorzuziehen, was
theoretisch einen Ticken schneller ist, weil es ist
gar nicht schneller. Was ist
eigentlich deine Meinung zum Protonrechner?
Weißt du nicht, was das ist?
Das ist übrigens,
was ich übrigens gerade mit
mit
Binary Search und sortierter Liste
ich gerade erklärt habe, ist auch der Grund,
warum die meisten Suchmaschinen
oder Index
basierten Suchmaschinen
keine Wildcards am Anfang
schnell suchen können, weil du machst
Binary Search und das ist sortiert
aufsteigend, also sprich, die Wörter
mit A kommen vorne und die Wörter mit Z
kommen hinten in der Liste. Wenn du darin
Binary Search machst und nicht
am Anfang matchen kannst,
bringt dir die ganze Sortierung nix.
Das heißt, deswegen sind
Suchmaschinen, also Index
basierte Suchmaschinen, wenn du eine
Wildcard am Anfang des Wortes
suchst, langsam,
weil sie eben den Index nicht richtig
verwenden können, sondern von Null bis Ende
drüber Schleife machen müssen.
Big brain talk,
aber ich hab hier educational
in den Text.
That is better format for your data.
Alright, mistake number
seven is using multiple if statements
instead of doing if else statements.
So if you just have if after if
awkward
with what you're doing, you probably
ähm
würdest du empfehlen, einen sehr starken
Rechner zu bauen oder einen günstigen oder
nachrüstigen starken Rechner?
Nachrüsten ist meistens pepega.
Es ist auch
viel besser, sich
eine ordentliche Grafikkarte
zu kaufen, anstatt, wie man
früher gesagt hat, zwei Mittelklasse per SLI.
Ist totaler Schwachsinn. Lieber eine
2080 Ti, anstatt zwei
äh äh äh 2070
oder sowas bescheuertes.
Find something that is better format
Meinung zur RAST, big brain,
excellent, exquisite Sprache.
Leider ziemlich hohe
Anlaufhürde,
Einstiegshürde.
Alright, mistake number seven is using multiple if statements
instead of doing if else statements.
So if you just have if after if
after if in each if statement,
only one of them
should really be true, then you should be
putting them in if else's.
And making sure it just flows like that.
Da hat er recht.
Dazu fällt mir bloß das hier noch ein.
Der richtige Weg, wie man äh lange ifs macht,
ist eindeutig der hier.
Und und nur der hier.
Ah.
Also scheiß auf sowas, was übrigens auch
noch falsch ist, was da oben ist.
Also immer das hier.
People read your code and also it doesn't make sense to do multiple condition checks.
Also it doesn't make sense to do multiple condition checks.
If the first one is true, the second one is true.
Ähm, wieso ist
if langsamer als ein switch?
Ist es nicht.
Nimmt sich, nimmt sich eigentlich nix.
And making sure it just flows like that.
It's easier to read.
Da hat er aber recht, da hat er aber recht.
Wenn du nämlich einfach nur ifs nimmst,
dann hast du das Problem, dass im Zweifelsfall
mehrere
äh mehrere ifs
matchen. Wenn du if else
else if else if else if else
nimmst, kannst du dir sicher sein, es matcht immer noch.
Nur eins.
If ist langsamer als ein switch.
Ist das so?
Das kann sein, allerdings wage ich mal
zu behaupten, dass das unterm Strich absolut
noch nicht mal messbaren
Unterschied macht.
Also it doesn't make sense
to do multiple condition checks
if the first one is true, the second
one you know is going to be false.
And so on. Alright, mistake number
eight is doing too much pre-processing.
Basically what happens is at the top
of a function or a file
or something, you basically just compute
all your variables and then
you have if statements that maybe
you'd be conditionally running stuff
and because you did all the processing
up front, some of the variables
may not be used and you're computing
stuff you really don't know.
So look at how you're doing things.
Das finde ich in C++ Sachen auch immer eklig,
wenn du dann, wenn sie dann zwischendrin
noch irgendwelche if defines
und sowas drinne haben, dass du gar nicht
weißt, ob der Code, den du jetzt liest, eigentlich
auch der Code ist, der am Ende ausgeführt wird.
Troem sagt, der C Sharp Klassiker ist,
dass 90% der Anfänger vergessen,
dass es Link gibt. Das stimmt.
Link ist ultra praktisch.
Man muss aber ein bisschen aufpassen,
weil Link ist teilweise
wirklich langsam. Und auch wirklich
in der Art und Weise langsam, dass man es
merkt.
Also manchmal ist einfach
die klassische Variante, eine popelige Schleife
das Beste, was man machen kann.
Was ist meine Meinung
zu Quantencomputern?
Meine Meinung dazu ist, dass
ich da zu wenig fundierte
Kenntnisse drüber hab, um was qualifiziert
zuzusagen.
Warum? Einfach alles im Vorfeld
berechnen und dann das Programm komplett
statisch machen. Schneller geht's
nicht. Dann besteht
mein komplettes Programm nur noch aus Printanweisungen.
Weil ich alles schon vorberechnet hab.
Be lazy
about generating the data
or computing values. Only compute it
when you need it. Now of course there are some
exceptions to that, but in general you don't want to just
compute everything at the beginning.
The next one is large
unorganized commits.
I sometimes do this myself.
Das hab ich jeden Tag, muss ich mir das
angucken.
So it's something that lazy programmers
do, where basically
you're fitting way too much stuff that
is not related to each other into a single
commit. You're waiting too long
to commit things and then you have
part A of your code being
committed with part B of your code and they have
nothing to do with each other. You should
be splitting these things up into two commits
or in smaller commits.
In der Theorie
hat er recht.
Es hält sich niemand wirklich so
hundertprozentig dran.
Das ist genauso wie
es sollte für alles Tests geben.
Mal Hand aufs Herz.
Nein.
Das ist halt nicht so.
Genauso wie
man sollte sich erst
einen Test ausdenken
bevor man anfängt.
Ist auch Schwachsinn, macht auch keiner
so.
Alles theoretisch
toll, praktisch, naja.
Ihr habt
95% Kaffee, das ist ziemlich gut.
Aber wenn ihr den Test nicht
fertig macht oder
einen Commit wechselt oder
den Commit nicht mehr benötigt,
ist es sehr einfach, den letzten
Commit zu entfernen.
Was ich bei Tests eigentlich
viel wichtiger finde, als dass es
möglichst viele Tests gibt,
dass man Tests einbaut,
die absichtlich fehlschlagen.
Ich habe den Eindruck, das machen
viele nicht. Also wenn du eine Funktion
hast, die zwei Zahlen zusammenrechnet,
nur überprüfe,
dass bei 2 plus 2
4 rauskommt. Aber ich sollte auch
einen Test machen, wo ich gucke,
überprüfe,
vielleicht kommt da 5 raus, so nach dem Motto
und dann schlägt es fehl.
Also das ist eigentlich
eine Sache, die
sollte man viel mehr Wert darauf legen,
dass man Tests macht, die quasi
nicht das testen, was man
machen wollte, sondern auch einfach
mal andere Sachen testet, ob die auch
wirklich kaputt gehen.
Ich teste, ob 2 plus 2 5 ist
und es sollte kaputt gehen.
Und wenn es nicht kaputt geht, stimmt
irgendwas nicht.
Ja, das hat jeder mal
gemacht, den Fehler.
Das kann alles sein, was
in Git nicht gebraucht wird.
Ja.
Das erste Git-Repo, was wir auf der Arbeit
gemacht hatten, wo wir noch so übelste,
krasse Hyper-Noobs waren,
was das angeht, 2000,
2011 oder so,
da haben wir
Target-Sets und Java
Binaries
ins Git gelegt.
Und nach einem Jahr oder so
war das Repo 2 GB
groß, wenn du es geklont hast.
Und dann war es so, dass
JavaScript Node-Module auf
GitHub oder in deinem Git
und dann auch API-Keys
drin war.
Ja, das ist Fail.
Ja, API-Keys muss man wirklich
aufpassen.
Das ist wirklich, das geht relativ
einfach. Ich habe auch schon
aus Versehen mal
Credentials committet, weil
du fügst die ein in ein File
bei dir und vergisst die in
irgendwie in Git Ignore zu schreiben oder sonst was.
Und zack,
ja.
Und natürlich environment-Variablen wäre
optimal, da liegt gar kein Fall da.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Der Typ
macht eh gute Videos.
Am besten finde ich die Gbait-Videos.
Und wenn er über Angular herzieht.
So, was haben wir gesagt? Gucken wir
als nächstes das Overclocking-Video.
Oder was wollen wir als nächstes gucken?
Diablo?
Overclocking? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Schau mal das neueste Video von dem.
Ist denn das
neueste Video?
Game-Changing, GPT...
Das ist diese...
Ist GPT-3
nicht diese AI, die irgendwie
Webseiten programmieren kann oder so?
Ja, das habe ich...
Ich kenne es nur vom Namen, habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt.
Diablo 2 ist doch besser als
Diablo 1, auf jeden Fall.
Hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren Video. Wir haben auf meinem Tisch
einiges an Z490-Hardware, denn
ich habe einen
10.900 KF geschickt bekommen.
Was zum Geier ist KF?
Intel-Bezeichnung. K ist
offener Multiplikator. Was ist F?
Hey, toller Stream.
Kannst du uns grüßen?
Äh, wen?
Euch? Tripli.de.
Hallo Tripli.de.
F für
fancy. F für fresh.
Verstehe.
Es gibt ja auch den 9900KF.
Bei dem ist eigentlich
nichts anderes. Es ist die identische CPU
wie ein 9900K, beziehungsweise
wie beim 10900K, nur dass die
Grafikeinheit, also die interne Grafikeinheit
deaktiviert ist. Und die
sollte auch wirklich nur deaktiviert sein. Also die ist
physisch, soweit ich weiß, vorhanden. Bedeutet
der Chip selbst ist komplett
identisch, nur dass eben
die Grafikeinheit nicht verwendbar
ist. Und da ist jetzt erstmal
die Frage, bringt uns das was? Denn es
gibt diverse Gerüchte, dass die KF-CPUs
besser zu übertakten sind, weil
die Abwärme geringer ist, weil keine
interne Grafikeinheit vorhanden ist,
weil dann der Chip quasi
eine größere Fläche hat, die verwendet
werden kann, um die Wärme abzuführen. Dadurch
sollen die Chips kühler laufen.
Ich persönlich frage mich aber eher, ob das quasi
eine recycelte CPU ist, wo
eben die interne Grafikeinheit vielleicht defekt
war und die Kanne selbst war
ein Top und man deswegen gesagt hat, alles klar,
können wir ja immer noch als KF-CPU verkaufen.
Deswegen werden wir heute testen,
ist ein 10900KF
besser als ein normaler 10900K
oder ist er vielleicht einfach nur
gleichwertig? Man muss natürlich im Hinterkopf
behalten, dass der 10900KF
nur minimal günstiger ist. Etwa
5% würde ich sagen, also
soweit ich die Preise im Kopf habe, ein 10900KF
liegt aktuell bei
ca. 500€ und ein 10900K
bei 520-530€
oder sowas
in der Richtung. Also quasi retail boxed.
Und da muss man sich fragen,
spare ich die 20€ oder behalte
ich die interne Grafikeinheit? Und man muss sich natürlich
auch fragen, brauche ich jemals überhaupt
eine interne Grafikeinheit? Das
werden wir uns jetzt mal eben anschauen.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Elgato
und dem neuen Streaming-Mikrofon Wave 3.
Mit Wave 3 bietet Elgato
ein bezahlbares und sehr hochwertiges
Zell-Out-Mode.
Das Tischmikrofon ist
komplett schwarz gehalten und wird über
USB-C mit dem Rechner verbunden. Der Drehregler
auf der Vorderseite ermöglicht schnelles
Umschalten zwischen den verschiedenen Modi
und Ändern des Pegels. Durchsammeltes Tippen
auf der Oberseite lässt sich das Mikrofon
stumm schalten, ohne dass dies in der Aufnahme
zu hören ist, wie z.B. wenn man auf einen Knopf
drücken würde. Die dazugehörige Wave
Link-Software funktioniert quasi als digitaler
Mischpult und so könnt ihr ganz einfach und
passend alles zusammenschalten, was ihr an
Wellen braucht und so für den Livestream mixen.
Mehr erfahrt ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Den ersten Test werden wir mit dem Asus
Maximus XII Extreme durchführen.
Asus Maximus XII Extreme.
Die Namen von Mainboards
werden immer besser. Dieses Board habt ihr
bei mir schon häufiger gesehen, denn ich habe ja
vor ein paar Videos schon mal was vorgestellt,
wo ich 30 10900K
CPUs getestet habe, um euch zu zeigen, dass
es diverse Unterschiede gibt,
wenn man 1 zu 1 die gleiche CPU
testet, mit 1 zu 1 der gleichen Einstellung.
Wir hatten damals Cinebench R20 getestet,
5,1 GHz bei 1,25V
und da hatten wir
dezente Unterschiede, was die Leistungsaufnahme
betrifft, nämlich Minimum
232W bis Maximum
278W und auch bei der
Temperatur von 79
bis 92 Grad Celsius. Also hier
reden wir über die Höchstwerte während dem
Cinebench R15 Run und es zeigt
einfach, ihr könnt unterschiedliche CPUs
nicht so einfach vergleichen. Also wir müssen
diese Werte, da haben wir schon mal so ein paar Durchschnittswerte,
die müssen wir im Kopf behalten, wenn wir uns
den 10900KF anschauen. Weil ansonsten
bekommt man sehr schnell den Eindruck,
wenn man nur eine einzelne CPU vergleicht
mit der anderen, dann denkt man, okay, die ist krass
besser, aber im Schnitt ist es dann vielleicht
gar nicht so. Da ich das Testing auf
diesem AsusBot gemacht habe, werden wir das auch
wieder hier machen, einfach nur
damit die Ergebnisse gleich bleiben.
Wenn wir uns ansonsten die CPUs mal so physisch
anschauen, haben wir natürlich keinen Unterschied.
Der einzige Unterschied ist die Beschriftung.
Wir haben K und KF
und der KF heißt SRH92.
Und der normale
K heißt eben SRH91.
Ansonsten natürlich andere Batchnummer, das ist klar.
Unterschiedliche Batches, wie die CPUs
gefertigt wurden, aber ansonsten äußerlich
erstmal kein Unterschied. Wie ihr sehen könnt,
identisches Setup zum letzten Mal.
Wir haben wieder den EK-Block drauf,
wir haben eine 360er
Kastenwasserkühlung, komplett identische
Setup.
Das sind immer fette Pipes hier.
Und CPU ist auch gleich konfiguriert, ihr seht
alle Kerne bei 5,1GHz und
Kernspannung aktuell 1,25V.
Ich werde jetzt gleich den Cinebench
starten und habe hier für euch schon mal
die vorherigen Werte notiert, dann ist
es einfacher zu beobachten. Also hier haben wir
CPU Package
und das war bei den anderen
30 CPUs maximal
zwischen 79 und 92 Grad Celsius,
dass wir so einen Richtwert haben.
Und hier das andere worauf ihr achten müsst
ist CPU Package Power.
Das lag zwischen 232
und 278.
Damit starten wir
jetzt den Cinebench.
Also auf den ersten Blick
könnte man den Eindruck bekommen,
dass die CPU wirklich tatsächlich
relativ kalt läuft.
CPU Leistungsaufnahme ist auf jeden Fall im unteren Bereich
verglichen mit den anderen CPUs.
Damit ist der erste Mythos quasi
schon beantwortet, schon
belegt. Hätten wir jetzt nur
einen einzelnen 10900K als
Vergleich verwendet, dann hätte es sein können
wir hätten vielleicht die CPU erwischt mit 92 Grad
und 278 Watt.
Dann könnte man jetzt denken,
wow krass, der 10900KF
ist ja so viel kälter und
so viel sparsamer was die Leistungsaufnahme betrifft.
Da wir aber schon
mehr CPUs zur Auswahl haben, wissen wir jetzt okay
mit 79 Grad Celsius war er
genauso kalt wie die
kälteste 10900K CPU, die ich getestet habe.
Und mit 243 Watt
Peak Leistungsaufnahme lag
er etwas über den
niedrigsten CPUs. Die niedrigste lag bei
232 bei den 10900Ks.
Da muss man sagen, die CPU
liegt genauso in dem Feld
wie die anderen. Es ist eben aber
immer noch nur eine. Man bräuchte jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich genauso 30 CPUs um das zu testen
um einen guten Eindruck zu bekommen.
Aber generell würde ich sagen,
es ist kein Riesenunterschied.
Man kann auch einen 10900K
erwischen, der auf die gleichen Werte kommt.
Ihr werdet jetzt euch wahrscheinlich
zu Recht auch fragen, aber wieso interessiert mich
Temperatur und Leistungsaufnahme erstmal?
Das war jetzt nun mal...
Also wenn er flüssig Stickstoff kühlt
ist es auch immer egal.
Wir werden jetzt natürlich noch die CPU
testen und schauen wie hoch können wir
diese individuelle CPU übertakten.
Das ganze machen wir aber
rein aus Interesse auf diesem
Z94 Gaming Carbon Wifi
mit einem EK Monoblock.
Weil ich das schon seit ein paar Wochen
hier liegen habe und ich unbedingt
das Bundle mal testen wollte. Ich fand es optisch
eigentlich ganz schön und wollte vor allem wissen
wie sind die Spannungswandertemperaturen
mit diesem Monoblock unter Last.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt den Test
was die reine Frequenz betrifft
auf diesem Bundle. Kommen wir jetzt mal
zu unserem vorhin angesprochenen Bundle.
Hier haben wir das MSI Gaming Pro Carbon Wifi.
Ich persönlich bin ja wirklich Fan
von dieser Carbon Optik.
Liegt vielleicht auch daran, weil ich so ein bisschen
Leidenschaft fürs Auto habe und da ist bei mir
auch ziemlich viel aus Carbon.
Ich persönlich finde das ganz cool.
Die Boards sehen ja wirklich ganz nice aus.
Wobei ich sagen muss
so ein bisschen RGB
warum nicht?
Davon sind die mittleren 12
für die CPU Spannungsversorgung.
RGB das ist dann die Big Brain Lösung.
Für die CPU integrierte
Grafikeinheit. Hier unten für System Agent.
Die anderen 12
sollten aber entweder geteamt oder gedoubled
sein. Ich habe auf der Rückseite keine Doubler gefunden.
Deswegen gehe ich eher von der Teamkonfiguration
aus. Das heißt wir haben 6
reelle Phasen dann auf 12 gedoubled
oder geteamt. Spielt keine
große Rolle ehrlich gesagt.
Was mir gerade aufgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht
warum mir das überhaupt aufgefallen ist, aber seht ihr
dass die Spulen
alle so ein bisschen unterschiedlich
angeordnet sind. Also die sind alle so ein bisschen
nicht hundertprozentig gerade.
Das hat mich so ein kleines bisschen getriggert
dass die nicht so perfekt drauf sitzen.
Das ist nur mir jetzt gerade aufgefallen.
Spielt technisch gesehen keine Rolle.
Ansonsten erwarte ich bei diesem Board
mit dieser Spannungsversorgung und gerade weil jetzt eben
ein Monoblock drauf kommt, keine Probleme.
Der Wasserkühler sieht so eigentlich auch ganz schick aus.
Also man sieht hier läuft das Wasser
rein, dann teilt sich das auf, läuft
außen rum und kommt dann
hier letztendlich wieder raus.
Wenn wir die Rückseite betrachten und mal kurz
ignorieren, dass ich hier schon wieder überall drauf
gefingert habe, dann haben wir hier eben CPU
Kontaktfläche in der Mitte.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Luft- oder Wasserkühlung?
Und dann hier eben die zwei Kontaktblöcke
für die Spannungswandler.
Wärmeleitpads und
Pasta sind drauf, damit kann jetzt der Kühler
installiert werden.
Schick ist natürlich auch wieder da, hat
geschaut, dass ich das Ganze auch richtig mache.
Dann kann ich jetzt
den Monoblock installieren.
Ja okay.
Die Pumpe läuft bei 100% und
da ist vielleicht ein bisschen Wasser im Kühlkreislauf.
Aber vielleicht können wir einfach mal kurz
so eine Sekunde genießen,
wie schön das aussieht
mit diesem ganzen Durchfluss, wenn
die Luftblasen sich so durch den Kanal
wälzen. Das sieht einfach immer mega schön aus.
Das sieht, das hat irgendwie
was, ja. Auch mit dem
RGB RAM.
Damit auch alles fertig aufgebaut. Ich habe auch schon
alles ausgelotet. Biosettings sind alle
eingestellt. Die schauen wir uns auch eben kurz
an. Ich habe die CPU soweit schon getestet.
Und kann schon mal sagen,
es ist wie erwartet. Es ist wie bei einem
normalen 10900K. Aber ich würde sagen,
wir gehen kurz ins Beihaus. Wir gehen kurz durch,
falls ihr euch die gleiche Kombination holen wollt.
Weil eigentlich finde ich das ganz attraktiv.
Für mich sieht es optisch cool aus.
Wird gut gekühlt. Spannungsveränderungen sind
vernünftig. Und wir liegen da preislich
glaube ich aktuell bei um die 400 bis
430 Euro für
Z490 mit Monoblock.
Du bist heute umgestiegen von
einem Noctur auf eine Wasserkühlung.
So sehr, sehr krass gestiegen und sehr, sehr teuer.
Aber wie gesagt,
damit kriegt man 5,2 GHz hin.
4266 auf dem Speicher.
Gehen wir mal kurz ins Beihaus.
Also ihr geht erst mal ins Advanced-Menü.
Dann links auf OC. Und jetzt machen wir
das Ganze 5,2 GHz. Wie gesagt, es ist
nicht alltagstabil. Aber jetzt für Cinebench R20
für den Alltag müsste ich jetzt hier
51 oder sogar 50 machen.
Das müssen wir dann noch genauer ausloten.
Auf OX habe ich auf 0 gemacht, dass sich
es bei Cinebench R20 nicht runtertaktet. Ring
bei 48. Dann
XMP geladen mit 4266.
Das hat auch problemlos funktioniert,
trotz Vollbestückung. Das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Bei Digital Power
habe ich die Load-In-Calibration auf Mode 3
gestellt, dass die Spannung nicht so
krass abfällt und unterlasst. Das ist auch
so eine Wissenschaft für sich.
1,32, was natürlich schon relativ
hoch ist. Aber wie gesagt, wir machen jetzt hier auch nur
Cinebench R20 und für den Alltag
dann eher 5 GHz, 5,1
und dann so um die 1,25 Volt.
Optisch, wie gesagt, noch mal
kurz so, wie es jetzt aussieht. Komplett
aufgebaut. Ihr müsst euch natürlich diese
Anschlüsse hier wegdenken. Die verwende ich nur,
weil es für mich angenehmer ist, so das
kurz zusammenzubauen und zu befüllen.
Aber ich finde, der Monoblock, der passt sich sehr
gut ein. Also man sieht ja auch hier diese
Linie, die hier reingefräst ist, passt zum
Design vom Board. Also sieht nicht so aus, als würde
es nicht dazu gehören. Finde ich sehr, sehr
stimmig und optisch auf jeden Fall ein Hingucker.
Dann werfen wir jetzt mal
einen Blick auf die Temperatur. Natürlich ist
in erster Linie jetzt erstmal die CPU-Temperatur
interessant. Mit einem Monoblock
sind die Temperaturen ja meistens
minimal schlechter als mit einem normalen Block.
Sieht soweit aber sehr, sehr gut aus.
Also wir haben ja 5,2 GHz, 1,32
Volt, also ein bisschen mehr als vorhin.
Sieht soweit
absolut in Ordnung aus. Das kann man für einen Cinebench
Run auf jeden Fall machen. Wie gesagt, Package
hier Maximum
82.
Package Power mit 240,
das passt auch. Und hier
Spannungswandertemperatur mit 50
Grad Celsius. Das ist echt mittlerweile voll die Wissenschaft
für sich. Ich kann mit den meisten
abkürzen und nicht mal mehr was anfangen.
Was ist GT Slice
Was ist CBO LCC
Ring, the fuck?
Sieht auf jeden Fall sehr gut aus. Da machen wir gleich
noch einen Test mit Prime95, was die
Spannungswander betrifft. Aber so auf den ersten
Blick, Temperaturen
sehr gut.
Excellent, exquisite Temperaturen.
Das passt auch zu der Geschwindigkeit
und Rammtakt. Das heißt, ich werde jetzt
nochmal kurz Prime95
laufen lassen für eine halbe Stunde, dass wir sehen,
wo die Spannungswandertemperatur sich hin
bewegt. Prime95 Temperaturen
sahen auch sehr gut aus. Maximal
hatten wir hier 63 Grad Celsius.
Absolut in Ordnung. Also ob
die Spannungswander jetzt 60 haben oder 70,
das spielt eigentlich keine große Rolle.
Mit dem Monoblock war das nicht anders zu erwarten
in dieser Region. Wie gesagt,
kann man absolut verwenden. 5,2 GHz,
R20 kein Problem. Ist ja, wie gesagt, alles
CPU limitiert. Nicht unbedingt
Mainboard limitiert zum 10.900
KF. Bleibt zu sagen,
es ist keine magische
Overclocking CPU, die plötzlich
besser läuft als alle andere, weil ich
teilweise eben YouTube-Videos oder Gerüchte
gesehen habe, dass die KF-CPUs
die absoluten Overclocking-Helden
sein sollen, weil ja die Grafikeinheit
deaktiviert ist.
Es ist wie üblich ein Glücksspiel.
Es kann sein, ihr erwischt eine CPU, die macht 5,1.
Also sozusagen.
Generell würde ich bei der KF-CPU
nicht mehr erwarten als bei einer normalen
K-CPU. Wenn ihr aber wisst, ich will
sowieso eine 2080 Ti zum Beispiel
verwenden und werde die interne Grafikeinheit
niemals brauchen und
will jetzt nicht warten. Wenn ich gamblen will, kann ich
auch Path of Exile spielen.
2900K-Verfügbarkeit ist ja aktuell nicht so gut.
Dann kann man auch ein KF kaufen.
Macht so keinen großen Unterschied.
Einer der weiteren Gründe, warum ich
mir keinen aktuellen Rechner, keinen neuen Rechner
aktuell kaufe, ich warte noch
bis es neue Nvidia-Grafikkarten gibt und
ich warte noch bis es neue
AMD Ryzen-CPUs gibt.
Ich hoffe ja, die kriegen das irgendwann bis Ende
des Jahres hin oder Mitte, Ende des Jahres
und dann wird zugeschlagen.
Wird mal wieder Zeit.
Wie gesagt, mir juckt es ja schon in den
Augen, seit letztem Jahr
mir was neues zu kaufen, aber ich
kann mich einfach nicht überwinden.
Ich kann mich einfach nicht überwinden.
Tja.
Übrigens, Chat.
Ich glaube, ich wurde vorhin richtig
gebatet. Ich habe nämlich gerade mal
da bin ich mal gespannt, was da ist.
Es war doch eben
jemand im Chat, der gefragt hat, ob ich
sie grüßen kann.
Ich habe mal geguckt, was das ist.
Ich glaube, das ist irgendein
Gold-Shop. Ich habe nebenbei
nämlich mal geguckt und ich frage
mich, warum die wollten,
dass ich sie im Stream grüße.
Wollen die damit irgendwie
Wollen die das
für irgendwas verwenden?
Ich zeige es jetzt nicht.
Ich zeige es jetzt nicht im
im Stream.
Ich will da keine Werbung für machen, ja.
Das sieht nach irgendeinem
Gold-Verkaufs-Tribade-Shop aus.
Ich habe nämlich nebenbei mal geguckt, was das
ist und
keine Ahnung,
warum die gegrüßt werden wollen.
Vielleicht wollen die das, das machen die
wahrscheinlich in ganz vielen Streams
und wollen, dass die Leute machen dann
vielleicht irgendein Video oder irgendein
Werbeclip draus und nach dem Motto
wir sind in der Community furchtbar beliebt
oder sowas. Da werde ich mal ein Auge
drauf haben. Da werde ich mal ein Auge
drauf haben, was da in Zukunft so
kommt, ja. Abmahnung ist
raus, Alter. Richtig
gebatet, aber ist schon schlimm mittlerweile, ey.
Gut, aber ich meine, was sollen sie mit
mit kurzem Moin XY
da anfangen, ja.
Kann man auf jeden Fall kaufen.
So, was gucken wir jetzt noch?
Uncertain Future of Diablo.
Gebatet-Song.
Den muss ich nicht aufmachen, den kann ich einfach
so abspielen.
Irgendjemand meinte doch vorhin, ich soll so
ein letztes 15-Sekunden-Video nochmal
mir angucken.
Was ist das denn hier gewesen?
Tolles Intro!
Ja.
...
Das ist echt gut.
Nein!
...
dass das erste Diablo eigentlich
rundenbasiert
sein sollte.
Bis ihnen dann die Entwicklung aufgefallen ist,
das ist so viel besser.
Diablo 2.
Beste, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Path of Diablo.
Ist ein Custom-Server, Custom-League.
Mit Gameplay-Anpassungen,
die das Game viel besser machen.
Viel besser als offizielle Battle.net-Geschichte.
Finde ich mega nice.
Kann man echt empfehlen.
Es gibt ein paar in Diablo 2 Mods, die richtig gut sind.
Hat sich gut verkauft.
Diablo 3 hat sich extrem gut verkauft.
Es heißt einfach
Path of Diablo.
Die haben auf der Website dann auch eine Anleitung, wie man spielen kann.
Aber gerade ist doof, gerade ist die Season vorbei
und die nächste Season startet in
einer Woche oder so.
Diablo 3 hat sich,
da bin ich mir heute sicher,
Herz 93, hast du den Shop dir angeguckt,
sieht original aus,
der Shop sieht original aus wie
der Scam-Shop, den wir vorher auf YouTube gesehen haben.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was die mit dem Gruß machen
jetzt. Lasst uns das
mal observieren.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Ich bin felsenfest
davon überzeugt, Diablo 3 hat sich
nur so gut verkauft.
Weil Diablo 2 ein absolut
legendäres Game war
und die Fans so ewig drauf gewartet haben
und alle wie verrückt gekauft haben,
ohne mal kurz zu warten.
Diablo 3 war nicht gut.
... zu be the best-selling Diablo game
of all time.
But even with its rich history, the future of Diablo
is uncertain. Between the misguided
and mishandled announcement of Diablo
and the larger discussion
about Blizzard as a company in general.
I think for good reason, there is a lot
of concern about whether or not the Diablo 3 is a good game.
Whether or not the next Diablo game is going to be any good.
But before we get into it, I want to take a moment
to touch on what Diablo has meant to me personally
over the years.
And I'll tell you, to this day, I still remember
my first introduction to the franchise.
It was summertime 1997.
12-year-old me probably just inhaled a couple of egg-
Als erster Diablo kann ich mich auch noch erinnern,
wo ich das gespielt habe.
Mein erster Kontakt mit Diablo war damals,
ich glaube,
von einer GameStar-Demo-CD.
Damals gab es noch Demos für Spiele.
Heute ist es nicht abends, wenn es dunkel wird,
wo die Leute spielen, sondern den kompletten Tag über.
Damit kann ich mich aber auch identifizieren.
Ja, ich habe auch in dem Alter quasi mehr oder weniger,
außer außer wenn ich in der Schule war, nur nur Sachen gespielt
von Half-Life bis dann später über Modem CS.
Who introduced me to the wonderful world of gaming.
Ich ess mal nebenbei ein bisschen was.
And then that one fateful summer night,
I was blessed with the opportunity to descend into the depths of hell.
I remember his room dimly lit by the monitor displaying the Diablo main menu,
the name engulfed in flames and those spinning pentagrams
that always seemed to go awkwardly fast.
But anyways, he looked at me and said,
dude, you can play first.
So I sat down, I hit enter and away we went.
Oh, that sounds, yeah.
Like many of you watching this,
one of my first real solid memories of the world of Diablo is,
is the trish from the big Lego Gamer Clan,
ca fascinating BGM
just so much much more
to remember.
I definitely hate this game.
Yeah.
Also, I guess, this did happen a lot with the trailers, right?
Zeit schon, ähm, längst
an Diablo 2 gearbeitet, wo Hellfire
als Addon released wurde.
Ne, das ganze Setting
mit den Kühen, also da gab's ja
dieser Typ, der in einem Kuhanzug war und dann gab's
diesen, ähm,
diesen Alien,
äh, organischen
Alien-Dungeon und diesen komischen
Diablo-Klon,
der aussah wie ein Transformer
und sowas. Ganz merkwürdig, ich hab nicht
verstanden, wie eine Firma Diablo
entwickeln kann und danach Hellfire als Addon
rausbringen kann. Wie gesagt, mir war damals nicht klar,
dass es zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Teams waren, die das entwickelt haben.
Und Hellfire für Diablo 1
hat damals auch richtig Beef
gegeben zwischen Blizzard und dem
Hellfire-Entwickler, weil, äh,
Diablo 2 sollte
nen, ähm,
nen Barb haben, also
Barbarian, klasse, die
links und rechts zwei Schwerter tragen konnte
und, ähm,
und noch irgendwas
und zumindest, eine der Sachen haben die
in Hellfire schon eingebaut und mussten es dann
per Patch deaktivieren.
12-String-Gitarre, as I made
my way through town, from one thatched
roof hut to another, talking to each
villager, including that drunk guy, who I
was pretty sure wasn't speaking English.
Then I found the cathedral and the
wounded townsmen warning me of the dangers
below. And the rest of that night
is sort of like this dreamy
haze.
The sanctity of this place
has been fouled.
A mix of staff attacks, fireballs,
enemies falling apart, with some notable
highlights, like when we first ran across
the butcher.
As fresh meat.
As was...
Wie lange braucht man circa, um Diablo 2
durchzuspielen? Naja, das ist ein bisschen wie
Passive Exile, also
so richtig fertig
bist du eigentlich nie. Wenn du einfach
nur die Main-Story durchspielen willst,
im normalen
Schwierigkeitsgrad, also
Akt 1 bis Akt 5,
und dir die wahnsinnigen High-Res
Zwischensequenzen anschauen willst,
das geht relativ schnell, 15 Stunden,
ganz schwer zu sagen.
Und auf normal, also du bist wahrscheinlich,
wenn du Speedrun mäßig machst, bist du
wahrscheinlich in zwei Stunden durch, ja.
Aber wenn du Snoop-Style mäßig spielst,
wie zum ersten Mal, und auf nix achtest, boah, ist das wahrscheinlich so.
Und auf nix achtest, boah, ist das wahrscheinlich so.
Irgendwie 10 bis 15 Stunden oder so.
Die wollen mir nicht erzählen,
der will mir nicht erzählen,
dass der 1997,
wo er das das erste Mal gespielt hat,
in einer Session
nachts das Spiel
durchgespielt hat. Never.
Das Spiel war relativ schwer,
wenn man sich null damit beschäftigt hat.
... in the process all over again.
This was the first of countless nights spent playing Diablo.
It also began a lifelong interest in RPGs of every kind.
Action, MMO, Shooter, whatever.
Games that have me playing for loot
are to this day some of my favorite.
Now you might be asking yourself,
Force, who gives a shit?
First off, don't be so rude.
And secondly, I kind of just wanted to share this story
to set the stage for my love of Diablo.
And I'm sure a lot of you have similar memories,
whether it's this game or any other from your childhood.
I think the interesting thing about moments like this
is we don't pick them.
I didn't know at the time that Diablo was gonna be
one of the pillars of my childhood,
but it was.
And like many other Blizzard games,
it absolutely helped to shape my life.
Ich muss sagen, Blizzard hatte damals einen echt guten Run.
Überlegt mal, die haben Diablo 2,
Starcraft,
Warcraft 3
und kurz danach noch WoW.
Also die hatten schon einen echt krassen Run,
so die paar Jahre.
So diese 6-7 Jahre hatten die einen wirklich krassen Run.
Lassen wir mal die ersten Warcraft und das erste Diablo außen vor.
Aber angefangen irgendwie in 99 oder so Starcraft
und Diablo 2 dann,
Warcraft 3
und später noch WoW.
Also die hatten schon einen echt heftigen Run,
was Spiele angeht.
Man hat das damals gar nicht so realisiert
und das einfach für normal angesehen.
Eines der besten Spiele ever.
Vor allem da gab es so heftige OP-Bilds.
Oder taken advantage of by some trained Sam.
Hammerdin.
Hammerdin-Beste.
I loved all of it.
So much so in fact,
that I wrote a few stories for my high school English class
about the adventures of my Paladin.
Wasn't the biggest hit with the classmates.
Fast forward to 2012,
I've been making YouTube videos for 2 years.
Damals wurdest du Shep angeguckt,
wenn du so Sachen gespielt hast.
Und dann in der Schule drüber erzählen hast.
So, was ist das für einer?
Heute ist das normal.
Heute stehen die auf dem Pausenhof, machen Loserdance, Fortnite.
Diablo 3 was about to launch,
and I decided to start covering the game.
I made a podcast with a few friends,
was pumping out videos for every little update
and overall was just hyped to play.
And then Diablo 3 launched
and was a total disaster.
Between their decision to make the game online,
which resulted in many people's inability to play for several days,
to the implementation of the real money auction house,
which initially I honestly thought was a cool idea,
plus this notion that we could earn money playing the game,
selling items that we found.
What I failed to realize at that time
was what this meant for the game's natural loot acquisition.
Rather than just being a cool way for gamers
to potentially earn some cash,
it ended up creating this ecosystem
where you felt cheated by the normal drop rates
and that, in not spending real money,
you were falling behind other players.
On top of that, Blizzard took a cut out of every sale,
which didn't go over too well with fans.
Das war eines der ersten Sachen, wo ich realisiert hab,
dass es mit Blizzard bergab geht.
...
Es ging nicht in meinen Kopf rein,
wie ein Entwickler wie Blizzard,
der eigentlich sonst so instinktiv die Sachen immer gut gemacht hat
und auch so im Sinne der Spieler auf so eine Idee kommen konnte.
I ended up falling off Diablo 3 a lot quicker than I expected,
especially since I had started making tons of YouTube videos
like a year prior to the game launching.
In fact, I think I quit the game after just a few weeks.
But over time, things changed.
They removed the real money auction house,
got an expansion and several content patches,
that added new gameplay and quality of life.
Diablo 3 hatte dann gar nichts mehr mit dem zu tun,
was ich spielen wollte.
Es war dann komplett self-found am Ende.
... life features and now, in 2020,
I can say that the game's in a pretty good spot.
Nein, es ist komplett self-found. Das ist mega fail.
Diablo 3 never had as big of an impact on me as the first two.
I've played a fair bit of the game over these years,
jumping in for the start of a new season,
to level up a character, play around with different builds,
and it's been entertaining enough and has kept me coming back.
Now that said, the game's been stagnant for some time now.
After Reaper of Souls came out in 2014,
fans were expecting a second expansion.
Diablo 2 ist, was Diablo angeht, absolut Peak-Diablo gewesen.
... went by with no news or announcement,
hope dwindled and was eventually smothered
when it was revealed that there would be no follow-up to Reaper of Souls.
Und die beste Pässe wechsel ist die eindeutig bessere Diablo-Alternative.
... und die beste Pässe wechsel ist die eindeutig bessere Diablo-Alternative.
Wir haben sogar Entwickler,
die sich in nem Video mit Leuten aus der Community zusammensetzen
und fragen sich hiermit im Video Fragen,
weil hat man sowas von Blizzard mal gesehen?
Und ich rede nicht von You guys don't have phones.
Oh ja, everyone exclaimed ,
it must be talking about Diablo 4.
How ignorant we were at the time.
In August 2018 was thatty妹
ham liRIght on chev Panel Bodiciаниеusgaben.
Jag brakeoint he der bara bz.
Wer schreibt die Texte für die Leute immer?
Wie gesagt, ich kann euch nur empfehlen, mal die alten BlizzCon-Auftritte zu gucken.
Beispielsweise, wo Jeff Kaplan sagt zu World of Warcraft, dass man Heiler, die nicht heilen, aus der Gruppe kicken soll und sowas.
So geile Auftritte letztendlich, die heute absolut unmöglich wären, weil instant irgendwelche Leute getriggert werden.
Oh nein!
Wir lieben Diablo. Wir wollen...
Zwei Wochen vorher geübt daheim.
Yeah!
Das ist nicht natürlich. Das hat er geübt vorher.
Guck mal, wie die Leute ruhig werden. So geil.
Pass mal auf.
Und jetzt sagt er Mobile Devices und alle dann auf einmal so...
Guck, eben noch alle übelst...
Mobile Devices.
Ich find's so geil.
...Mobile Devices als Plattform für ein neues Diablo-Spiel.
Das ist so der Wahnsinn.
Ich find, das ist so geil.
Das ist quasi Heimspiel für Blizzard.
Da muss ich mal überlegen, wie entkoppelt von der Realität man sein muss als Firma in dem Fall,
dass man...
...so was nicht kommen sieht.
Du musst komplett realitätsfremd sein.
Und ich kann's auch nicht verstehen, weil da haben ganze Abteilungen einfach total versagt.
Blizzard entwickelt Spiele nicht blind.
Und Blizzard analysiert auch sicherlich die Gruppen, wer ihre Spiele spielen wird.
Und ja, natürlich haben die gesagt, Big Stonks.
Ähm...
...Mobile Games boomen.
Und wahrscheinlich wird Diablo Immortal auch ein relativ gutes Mobile Game.
Allerdings, wo sie komplett von der Realität entfernt abgehoben sind, ist,
weil es noch nicht mal jemand dort für möglich gehalten hat überhaupt,
dass man das besser nicht in der Art und Weise auf der BlizzCon präsentieren sollte,
weil irgendwie keiner dran gedacht hat, dass wer die Leute sind, die auf die BlizzCon gehen.
Das sind Leute, die fliegen dahin, die fahren dahin, die kaufen sich...
...Eintrittskarten.
Das sind Oldschool- und zu 95% PC...
...also die young-lehrerische Fans, teilweise Oldschool-Leute, die schon lange dabei sind,
die 95% auf dem PC spielen.
Ähm...
Dass da keiner drauf gekommen ist und das Kommen gesehen hat, ist...
...da haben ganze Abteilungen heftig versagt.
I'm not a huge fan of mobile games.
Wie er guckt.
They are an inferior gaming experience.
But I also realize that there's a massive market...
...and there are tons of people all over the world who do enjoy playing games on their phones.
So, for that reason, I'm not surprised that Blizzard is looking to make more mobile games.
But that wasn't the issue.
The issue with the Diablo Immortal announcement was one of time and place.
It came at a time when people were highly anticipating Diablo 4...
...and it happened at a place, BlizzCon, that is filled with the most hardcore fans of Blizzard games...
...which are predominantly PC-focused.
Yeah.
And to make matters worse, when they got the fairly negative reaction to the announcement of Diablo Immortal...
...they doubled down with comments like this.
I don't have any plans at the moment to do PC.
Da sieht man auch, er hat absolut nicht realisiert und war komplett überrascht von der Reaktion.
Wäre er das nicht gewesen und hätte mal drüber nachgedacht, dann hätte er was anderes gesagt.
Dann hätte er versucht, es ein bisschen diplomatischer auszudrücken.
So nach dem Motto, wir evaluieren zurzeit eine PC-Version oder irgendwas und nicht zu sagen, no.
Weil du willst eigentlich deinen Fans nicht live auf der Bühne sagen, ihr kriegt nicht das, was ihr wollt.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich doof.
Deswegen, der war komplett überrascht von der Situation.
Do you guys not have phones yet?
Das ist so Pains Champ.
You can play on your tablet too.
Yes, Blizzard, we all have phones.
The person who paid the hundreds or thousands of dollars to travel to and attend your events
has been playing your game for the past 25 years on PC.
Most of your fans like PC games.
Wieso machst du keine Videos mit dem Friseur?
Nee, erstens mache ich gerade überhaupt keine Videos, weil ich keinen Bock auf YouTube habe.
Und zweitens ist der Friseur anderweitig beschäftigt.
...surprised by the reactions they got.
The response to the response that they weren't expecting was them assuring fans,
that other people were surprised by the reactions they got.
that they weren't expecting was them assuring fans, that other people were surprised by the reactions they got.
And the other Diablo projects that were not on phones are in fact still in the works,
which finally brings us to Diablo 4.
The following year, at BlizzCon 2019, we finally got the announcement of Diablo 4.
And it was grim, dark, and seemed to be exactly what fans wanted.
4!
Nope.
Ach doch, jetzt kommt dieser Trailer, dieser Diablo, das Diablo Gameplay.
Was letztes Jahr oder vorletztes Jahr, letztes Jahr, was?
Was letztes Jahr, glaube ich, kam, wo ich so absolut nicht begeistert war von.
So what do we know about Diablo 4?
Well, quite a lot actually.
At the BlizzCon announcement we had a great outline of the game's various systems and mechanics,
and we also got to see a decent chunk of gameplay.
In fact, I played the game myself quite a lot.
So let's go over everything that we do know about Diablo 4.
The game's story is taking place decades after Diablo 3, Sanctuary is in shambles,
and Lilith, the mother of humanity,
has been summoned.
Why is she here?
What does it mean?
Let's just assume it's probably not a good thing.
So Artstyle-mäßig fand ich den Trailer richtig nice gemacht,
auch wie das von der Atmosphäre aufgebaut war,
aber mich hat das eigentliche Diablo Gaming so gar nicht überzeugt.
The Diablo games have been described as action RPGs,
which makes this next part pretty interesting.
Wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, das sieht aus wie ein Unity-Demo-Level.
4!
So what's the difference?
Well, the game features one massive world with five distinct regions that can be seamlessly explored,
meaning you can walk from the top of the map all the way down to the bottom with no loading screens,
and the game's story, being non-linear, will be breaking away from the series' traditional act structure.
You'll still be able to teleport around the map via waypoints,
but the game will also include a brand new mount system.
Players will get access to mounts,
that can cut down on travel time, have customization through armor, pieces and saddles,
as well as hanging trophies, and give access to these unique dismounting abilities.
The open world will include much of what you expect from Diablo and RPG games in general.
There are dungeons, world events and bosses.
The dungeons will be instanced to you and your party,
but the rest of the world and the towns that act as social hubs will be a shared space.
So as you walk around a world event or boss, you will probably come across other players.
And if you're feeling in the competitive mood, the game will also have
PvP zones, which will likely offer some sort of incentive to get players to fight,
other than the thrill of victory.
And the game will have hundreds of randomly generated dungeons,
each with their own dungeon-specific events and objectives.
There's also going to be endgame variations of the dungeons through this key system
that can add difficulty ranks,
and affixes to give players more varied content with strategic...
Erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Path of Exile Maps.
...depth, and much like the open world,
they said there will be no loading screens between dungeon levels
for a more seamless exploration experience.
Enemy faction families will be returning,
with things like the fallen skeletons and these drowned enemies have been revealed.
The different enemy types working together,
like you'll have swarmers running up to surround a player,
and then strong enemies in the front,
and ranged and caster enemies,
in the back.
Elites with strong affixes return,
and of course, there will be bosses.
They've also added this brand new stagger system...
Habt ihr gerade dieses...
Moment mal.
Das sieht aus wie das Path of Exile Monster in dem...
Skelette in dem Rad aus...
aus Akt 1.
Ach nee, das ist nur was mit einem riesen Bogen.
Hab mich verkruckt.
...bosses.
They've also added this brand new stagger system,
letting players use crowd control abilities on a boss,
and if you do this enough, it will fill up a bar,
they then become staggered,
which will change the boss's phase and add some new fighting mechanics.
And then of course we've got...
Dazu muss ich sagen,
ich glaube,
dass in einem Action-RPG, wo es hauptsächlich ums Monsterschnetzeln geht,
Spieler keine großartigen Boss-Mechanics wollen.
Du willst hingehen, den Boss bashen und den nächsten Boss bashen und weitermachen.
Du willst keine 3 Minuten Boss-Fights mit Mechanics haben.
Aber vielleicht, je nachdem wie das Game gemacht wird,
kann es auch falsch liegen.
Kommt drauf an, wie es ins Game integriert ist.
Doch, ich will...
Okay, ist ja gut, Chat.
Der Chat will's.
Na, wenn's der Chat will.
Ja, aber in Path of Exile sind die Bosse zum größten Teil einfach
Brute Force drauf in den Maps.
Ja, du hast ein paar...
Einzeldinger, wo an irgendwelche Skripting-Events geknüpft sind,
aber die meisten Bosse sind drauf, um Bursten gut ist.
Ist das ein Skill-Tree?
Oder ist das so ein komisches Diablo-3-Verschnitt-Skill-System?
Du hast Skill-Points, die du entlockst,
und ein Talent-Tree, um durchzugreifen,
um deinen Spielstil zu kustomisieren,
mit den stärksten und am stärksten Talenten,
die am Boden jedes Trees sind.
Und natürlich, was wäre ein Loot-Game ohne das Loot?
Diablo 4 wird sechs Item-Rarities von normal zu mythisch haben,
mit den höheren Rarity-Items,
mit mehr Affixes.
Items-Sets sind zurück,
aber der Fokus wird dieses Mal auf Legendäre sein,
mit hunderten von ihnen im Spiel,
um den Spielern mehr Veränderung zu bieten.
Rune werden auch wiederkehren,
da Spieler eine Condition-Rune und eine Effekt-Rune kombinieren können,
um ein Rune-Wort zu formen.
Und Bob Lizard ist...
Im Prinzip wie Diablo 2.
... mit den Spezifiken der Itemisierung,
und mit den Spezifiken der Itemisierung,
es gibt natürlich...
Also, hier AFL sagt, er ist hyped auf das Game, ich gar nicht.
Ich hab, äh, das komplett aufgegeben, dass da von Blizzard was Gescheites kommt.
Ich lass mich aber gerne positiv überraschen.
... Gold-Diablo-Community that has plenty of suggestions themselves.
So that's more or less what we know about Diablo 4.
Sounds pretty good, right?
And yeah, it is good.
Last BlizzCon, I got several hours of hands-on time with the game.
I played each class, explored the world and dungeons,
checked out public events,
and tried my hand at a world boss.
And like most everything Blizzard puts out, it was fun.
And in fact, it was even pretty well put together for such an early build of the game.
Now, there are a lot of people who are still really worried about Diablo 4.
One of the biggest complaints being that Blizzard isn't the same company that it once was,
and you can no longer trust them to make a good game.
And I agree that Blizzard has changed.
Their games don't quite have the same...
...spunk that they used to.
Like, I would describe Blizzard's older titles as polished, but with sharp edges.
And nowadays, everything's a little softer, a little more...
Man könnte das als Magic irgendwie beschreiben, so...
...or homogenous.
So das, was man nicht richtig erklären kann,
aber so das richtig Besondere bei den Games fehlt.
...and is a little more friendly to a mass audience.
But I do disagree with this idea that they don't still make great games.
Besides that one massive exception, which was...
...their recent botched attempt to remake Warcraft 3,
everything else that they've put out over these past 15 years,
I have genuinely enjoyed.
Overwatch, Heroes of the Storm, Hearthstone, Diablo 3, Starcraft 2,
and the various World of Warcraft expansions are all games that I sunk hundreds to thousands of hours into.
Now, there is a separate conversation to be had about whether or not you're okay with giving Blizzard your money,
and I absolutely would not suggest going to them, or any corporation for that matter,
for any moral guidance.
In fact, if you kinda wanna see a deep dive into some of the failings of Blizzard as a company in...
Das haben wir. Das haben wir das letzte Mal geguckt.
...recent years, I suggest checking out this pretty awesome recent video from the Actman.
But, if we're strictly talking about whether or not they make good, fun games, I would say yes.
I have had fun with nearly every single Blizzard game, and I would expect Diablo 4 to be no different.
Now that said, Blizzard...
Blizzard isn't the same company it used to be.
And in much the same way, yeah, Diablo itself isn't the same franchise it once was.
To me, the games used to feel like this big adventure, like I was going on this exciting expedition.
And now it just kinda feels like I'm indulging in my lizard-brain's pleasure-response systems
by repeating the same activities over and over and over and over again
to get that sweet dopamine hit, motivating me to do it for a little while longer.
How much of that is the game's fault?
How much is me being 35, having...
...played hundreds, if not thousands of games, and making novel experiences that much harder to come by?
I don't know.
What I do know, though, is that I still love games, and maybe despite my better interest, I still love Blizzard games.
Blizzard is different, Diablo is different, I'm different, but I'm also hopeful.
I hope that Blizzard can...
Also, ich lass mich...
Ich würde mich gerne positiv überraschen lassen von Diablo 4.
Wirklich.
Ich will das nicht von Anfang an...
Also, ich sag nicht von Anfang an.
Es muss scheiße werden.
Aber ich hab halt so diese Vorschusslorbeeren, die gibt's halt nicht mehr.
Da kann ich ihm zustimmen.
Exzellent.
So, Leute.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ich hab jetzt hier noch einen halben Teller Nudeln.
Den würde ich jetzt futtern.
Also, ich würde jetzt off gehen, meinen halben Teller Nudeln noch fertig futtern.
Und vielleicht komm ich dann in, sagen wir mal, einer halben Stunde wieder on und wir leveln den Path of Exile-Character fertig.
Bis 70, 75.
Sollt ihr heute sehen.
Wollen wir heute locker drin sein, wenn wir 14 Uhr haben.
Peewee Grind, ja.
Ich fand's cool.
Ich mein, wir waren gestern bis 24 Uhr ungefähr on.
Und es waren so 70, 75 Leute am Start.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht so wahnsinnig viele interessiert.
Aber ich mein, so die Hardcore-Leute sind immer noch am Start gewesen.
So, ähm, und morgen am Montag...
Ihr wisst ja, ich arbeite ja nur vier Tage die Woche.
Montags hab ich immer frei.
Montag geht's weiter.
Da basteln wir wieder ein bisschen Raspberry Pi Zeugs.
Da hab ich ein paar Sachen, die ich ausprobieren will.
Ich kann euch nicht versprechen, dass ich Montag on komme, aber ich hab ein paar Sachen geplant, die ich ausprobieren wollte.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
GG Emote, nice.
Ja, gebt neue Emotes.
Ich hab noch 20 Emotes oder 25 Emotes frei.
Also Leute, mal gucken.
Ich denk mal, ich komm dann gleich wieder on, aber ich ess jetzt erstmal in Ruhe was.
Oder besser gesagt, ich ess jetzt erstmal in Ruhe fertig.
Dann komm ich on und wir spielen eine Runde Path of Exile.
Machen den Charakter auf 75 und, äh, kaufen ein bisschen Gear.
Aber genug Currency mittlerweile am Start.
Also, bis später.
See you.